ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
another exciting episode of Tim cast IRL
in today's news Fox News agrees to match
employee donations to the satanic temple
Trevor Project and Planned Parenthood a
new Gallup poll finds that belief in God
has reached a new low I guess we've
reached a lot of new lows in this
country lately and the doj is going to
sue Texas for their immigration policies
or at least the way that they intend to
enforce those but first i'm going to ask
all of you to smash that like button and
become members at timcast.com if you
become members at timcast.com you're
going to get access to the after show
where we are uncensored you'll also be
helping us to build culture and help
grow the Empire we're also shouting out
a member tonight and a business he
started we're thankful for his support
we want to show some mutual love GC
Windsor contemporary neckties and men's
fashion accessories check out this
upgrade to the necktie the GC Windsor
which never sacrifices tradition or
Integrity the create later Jeffrey de la
nuez is one of our members and someone
were happy to support So visit the
website at gcwindsor.com to see the vast
array of combinations available and cygc
Winsor will reinvigorate professional
fashion once again by going to his
website you can sign up for the
newsletter and pre-order the sets
joining us today is writer radio talk
show host presidential candidate he even
has a star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame
The One and Only Larry Elder thank you
for joining us today thank you so much
for having me I really appreciate it
yeah of course of course did that sound
sincere absolutely it was totally
sincere good got off to a good start
yeah yeah well we're so happy to have
you here today I'm Hannah Claire brimlow
I'm a writer for timcast.com and on this
Friday I hosted culture war in Tim's
absence so I'm grateful for all of you
who tuned in and I am so happy to be
joined by one of my favorite people
Brett dasvik oh
hello yes I'm Brett dasovic I am the
host of Pop Culture crisis Monday
through Friday 3 P.M right here on
youtube.com
and I am search.com that episode of
cultural was spicy wasn't it Serge and I
just went through some stuff this
morning yeah it was a battle in here
yeah yeah anyways take it away Tim yeah
absolutely let's Dive Right into our
first story here Fox News has said they
will match employee donations to satanic
temple the Trevor Project Planned
Parenthood and the splc unbelievable all
the organizations of course that we
would hope Fox would be against because
they stand for all the things that Fox's
audience wants destroyed in the United
States but here we are whistleblowers
from Fox News revealed that the company
uses an app called Fox giving to match
employee donations to approved
organizations which again include the
satanic satanic temple the Trevor
Project which by the way for those of
you have been following the show no has
a chat room portal that they advertise
to minors that allows for you to speak
to an adult about your sexual identity
and if you hit the escape button three
times it clears your entire browser
history cool is that the one with that
Daniel Radcliffe speaks for yeah okay
yeah so if that's not bad enough of
course they're also matching donations
to Planned Parenthood and the splc
they're willing to match donations up to
one thousand dollars so the
whistleblowers took the story to the
blaze which reports that fox is going to
subsidize some of the very activist
groups that despise and seek to ruin the
Network's viewers
evidencing a complete disregard and
hatred for its core audience we've seen
a lot of shenanigans from the people
over at Fox lately them getting rid of
Tucker Carlson was certainly in my
estimation of blunder on their part I
also think it was bad for the American
people the way I've described this in
the past is that CNN tells you what
you're supposed to believe and then Fox
exists to tell you what you're allowed
to believe if you're not going to
swallow what they're trying to give you
over at CNN Fox offers you this
alternative that's still somewhat Market
safe it's still somewhat PC and they
tell you this is the outer limit this is
the boundary once you've hit this you
can't go further to the right or else
you're a nut job in a conspiracy
theorist part of the value of Tucker
Carlson on that network was that he
pushed that Overton window further to
the right they got rid of him that is
one step that Fox News has taken and
what I would argue is a long series of
steps to insult their core audience and
harm the movement what do you guys think
all right my first question is what did
fox say in response to the blaze piece
did they put out a statement did they
deny it do they confirm it I haven't
seen any comments from them yet and I
will say there are a lot of Corporations
that offer this type of match giving
right so Google did this for a long time
and I know that there were cases of
employees opting to donate to
conservative causes and Google said no
we won't do it and so for me I I can't I
don't personally know the whistle Lara
Fox but I would love to see what
organizations Fox is denying if they're
saying yes to the splc if they're saying
yes to uh Planned Parenthood they're
saying yes to satanic temple who are
they also saying yes and who are they
saying no to it's just hard for me to
believe that fox would do that
particularly with an organization like
splc I mean this is an organization that
once called Dr Ben Carson a hate monger
and so I just I'm a little skeptical I
like to see what fox has said in
response because there are a lot of
people that are mad at Fox and uh they
come forward they give a story and next
thing you know people run with it so I
just I'm skeptical all the time and I'm
skeptical about this too yeah that's
fair I think that's a prudent approach
to take to to wonder what their
statement is and I guess we'll see how
they respond to this I've definitely by
been disturbed by some of what foxes
done in the past year but but I would
agree that's probably a safe course of
action and clearly I'm upset about
Tucker Carlson not being there yeah I
announced for president on April 20th
which turned out to be Tucker Carlson's
neck to the last show by the way I
started not to announce on April 20
because that's Hitler's birthday I'm a
little
suspicious about that and we started to
put it off for one week I'm happy we
didn't because then we would have been
on somebody else's show we ended up
being on the highest rated show in the
prime time so you believe that fox is
essentially it's the outer limits of
what you're allowed to to believe
publicly without being considered like
far right like yeah do not pass go do
not become oan yeah yeah well I I think
that's one way of looking at it they're
sort of uh they're conservative I think
they're probably more in line with
establishment conservatism but people
see them as safer I think so Fox as
compared to you know an organization
that you mentioned One America Network
or some of these other networks and
online Publications has somewhat uh of
an increased level of credibility in the
mainstream I would say you know Tim I
have to I have a question uh of course
do we have
you if you want to be Tim you know I'm
the black Tim of white supremacy yes
okay if you want to be the black Timber
white supremacist you're more than more
than welcome uh you know you know to
both of my teams the the thing is I I do
feel as though I have to raise a
question of uh uh uh First Amendment
rights right so yeah and I'm not an
expert in this but uh if a company
offers to match your giving if it's
wrong for Google to say we won't match
your gift to a right-wing organization
we disagree with is it wrong for Fox to
say we won't uh give money to a
left-wing organization that you you
choose to pay here it is surprising to
me that someone who wants to give money
to the splc works at Fox but you never
know some people media yeah I mean
there's a lot of people in media who are
on the left you know just like there are
people who work for some left-wing
organizations who are more conservative
and just don't talk about it I would
suspect it's the case that there are
left-wing people who work for fox and
aren't super open about it or maybe they
are more open about it I've never been
to their Studio what I will say is
there's two different ways to look at
your question here there's the legal
question and there's the moral question
I can't answer the legal question uh I'm
sure Larry was more hope to answer that
one but in terms of the moral question I
don't think there's anything wrong with
fox saying no we would be unwilling to
uh match a donation to organizations
that despise our viewers and everything
we stand for
I mean but legally I'm curious
yeah yeah you'll see no reason why they
can't have a policy like that we're not
going to match company match to
organizations we don't like and that
assault our our viewers yeah yeah
absolutely you so you brought up a story
with Google and and you asked if it's
okay in in both circumstances I'm
curious what the Fallout ended up being
for Google uh well with Google you
know the story personally for some of
these employees they they battled
through and got the donations but
obviously then had a Target on their
back right they were then a band of
people who believed in the wrong
organization so it is it is a question
of what what the recursion are I tend to
agree with you if they're a private
company perhaps they should have a value
and I think it would show Integrity to
what they uh presume to represent in in
this country of course you know I think
fox has done some some good things I
think there are things that I question
of course it is a major corporation and
I think ultimately it serves its its
bottom line which you know is is a
reality of uh of their business
um and so it's not yeah imagine being
like in an industry full of people where
you're like maybe you're like the one
right-wing guy at CNN imagine being the
one left-wing guy at Fox News you're
just you're just the one guy hanging out
there that doesn't sound like well there
are people like that I mean that's what
project Veritas found out about CNN yeah
a couple of people were on tape and they
were upset about Jeffrey Zucker and
about how every morning he would have a
nine o'clock meeting or whatever hour it
was basically telling people what to say
this guy was ticked off to about it he
said he had a personal Vendetta against
Donald Trump tell us what to say to the
exclusion of other of other issues there
are people within probably every
organization that feels that way do you
think that the the trajectory fox has
been on where they've lost some of the
support you know since the election and
what's going on now so obviously since
Tucker has gone does that fall in line
kind of with project Veritas since the
exit of James O'Keefe where I see people
like I still follow project Veritas on
social media but I don't see the same
kind of vigor for the for the cause that
you saw there before like there it feels
like they're just they've lost the
momentum that they had before well in my
opinion it's hard to say that people
like uh Mark Levin or Sean Hannity are
not aggressive they're not passionate
they are but I do think Fox
underestimated how popular Tucker
Carlson was and how much he meant to the
whole organization reminds me of when
Johnny Carson was on uh late night and
when he'd go on vacation uh The Today
Show or whatever show it was in the
morning of the Today show I would have a
lower rating oh I meant I meant more
like the the audience Vigor like I don't
see the same like I felt like the
support behind those organizations from
Their audience ratings stole that yeah
the ratings are down almost 50 yeah I
mean I think that is a good point uh for
me Fox is interesting for a lot of
reasons one of the things that I would
question is
um if the audience are reacting to the
content and the content is ultimately
driven by executive decisions and of
course we'd have to kind of examine
what's going on with the Murdoch family
to completely understand uh the
direction that fox is taking and I'm not
sure how to speculate on that but I know
that you know as as leadership changes
hands of course there can be questions
about the direction of the network right
um I also find that you know again I
think there's a place for conservative
media of course and of course there
should be conservative voice in
mainstream media but because we tend to
work on alternative media we work on you
know the internet emerging media
um there the thing that I love about
conservative audiences is that they are
always willing to seek new sources and I
find that to be refreshing in some ways
fox has to compete with more because we
are growing stronger than CNN's sort of
mainstream media does because I just
don't see the same parallel to what we
are building here on the left they see
they take their CNN they set it and
forget it and just use that as their
source for everything is their source of
information for everything whereas
people who are tend to be right leaning
are excited to go out and explore new
avenues of people to listen to and
totally I think Brett the miscalculation
was that fox historically they've seen
big names depart Bill O'Reilly left
train kept ongoing Megan Kelly left
train kept on going Lou Dobbs you know a
lot of people have left and nothing
happened and I think they assume that
you organization was bigger than any one
individual and they underestimated how
how big Tucker Carlson was yeah I mean
he was absolutely massive and people
really loved him part of what I valued
so much about him were the things I laid
out earlier about the fact that he was
willing to entertain and even promote
ideas that other people in the
mainstream weren't what he was saying
about January 6th and Ray Epps were
things that I was very surprised to hear
on television and about Ukraine and
about Ukraine I mean and these are
things that really lended credibility to
this narrative not just because he was
saying it on television that's huge in
terms of Optics but also because he was
supplying good evidence for this story
and so when he released the Jan six
tapes on television I thought that was a
massive victory for truth and for the
fight against the hegemonic narrative
that the left-wing media forces the
American people to stomach and so when
he left you had a lot of conservatives
saying things like ultimately this is
really good for Tucker Carlson because
he's better off without Fox and I don't
think anyone was or is doubtful that
he's going to be tremendously successful
at whatever he does exactly but what was
really sad for me was that even though I
was well aware of the fact that he'd be
successful there is something about the
credibility that television lends to a
person that makes their ideas more
palatable to the American people yeah
like people were talking about because
he did his he did his interview on
Tucker on Twitter with Andrew Tate which
cracked like what 80 to 100 million
viewers and they were trying to pass it
off I was like this is the most watched
interview of all time the problem is
when you look at that list it's all ABC
NBC it's a lot of 60 Minutes Diane
Sawyer so it automatically is kind of
discounted by people because like what
is a view on Twitter review is just
somebody scrolling past it so the
legitimacy that being on a network slot
at a specific time gives credibility in
a way that's a lot easier if you're
trying to share something with somebody
who may not be informed on what you're
talking about it's a big big plan yeah
that he no longer has no question about
it he also went after pharmaceutical
companies yep uh and if you look at the
commercials not just on Fox but
everybody uh ozympic their sister is
that there's this there's that there's
all these drugs that the Pharmaceuticals
are pushing they're a huge Advertiser
and so he was essentially going after
many of the advertisers that are on Fox
yeah and um that took a great deal of uh
cashews yeah I mean look when you have
positions that are not television safe
it can't make sense
um I mean he had positions that weren't
television safe that's what we value
about them but when you're in that
position it's it's kind of an
inevitability that you're going to get
pushed uh off of the network especially
if they're trying to stand by their
advertisers rather than ensuring that
the viewers get the truth on those
matters one of the things that I think
is really a testament to Tucker Carlson
and the work that he did was after you
know when he was let go from Fox I
believe around the same week Don Lemon
was let go from CNN and when Don Lemon
was let go everyone was speculating is
this because of the extremely ignorant
comments that he made the Vivek is this
because of him saying that women aren't
in their Prime past their 40s in front
of those women when when Tucker got let
go it was was it this story was it that
story I mean people were talking about
important journalistic work that the
establishment might not like when Don
Lemon got let go no one was thinking oh
you know that one story he told really
Shook Up The Establishment and ruffled a
lot of feathers it was it was petty
drama that people were speculating he
had to have been let go over and that is
it's not just true of Don Lemon that's
most journalists today when Don Lemon
was let go the issue to me was what took
him so long
the dumbest people on television uh
always playing the race card hated
Donald Trump refer to him as a racist I
could go on and on and on but he even
took a shot at me one time what did he
say he said I wasn't very smart why'd he
say that Dennis Prager was on his show
and he said it's my friend Larry Elder
says and and Don Lemon said well why are
you quoting Larry Elder he's not that
smart oh he's very very smart and Don
Lemon says no just because he's on
conservative radio doesn't mean he's
with it that's what he said
yeah I was gonna say that's not like
he's not demonstrating his own
intelligence there I just I I think
that's one of the the things about uh
personalities and media that I find so
interesting especially when we contrast
Tucker uh obviously I have never had Don
Lemon specifically attacked me but
someone who feels as though they are a
avert they are a benefit to the
institution that that CNN is better
because Don Lemon is there that type of
um
I'm gonna use the word self-confidence
but I really really mean is ego is is
toxic and I think that really uh
inhibits someone's uh performance in
work whereas Tucker Carlson despite that
effect that he got big really did
continue to push to have truth and to
see this Mission and connect to his
viewers and I just you know I don't see
the same trajectory of Don lemon's
career and so they become different
value assets to Fox Tucker was a risk in
a lot of ways but Don Lemon was just a
drain on resources that's a very polite
way of of saying Hannah clear that Don
Lemon is dumb and cover Carlson is not I
was on uh don lemon's show Once I think
the last time I was on shockingly
and we're talking about racism and I
pointed out that the time and CNN some
years ago had done a study of black
teenagers and they asked them whether or
not race so it's a major problem in
America the majority of them said yes
but then they asked the black teenagers
whether racism was a big problem a small
problem or no problem in their own daily
life 89 of the black teens said a small
problem or no problem in my own daily
life in fact more black teens and white
teens said failure to take advantage of
available opportunities was a bigger
problem than racism I said that to Don
Lemon and that was the last time I was
on the show shocking yeah why why we
want to kick you off for that why would
I quote why would I poll done by CNN on
CNN well this is what he was saying on
CNN all right and this is so very smart
according to you yeah yeah according to
him not a very smart move if you want to
get invited back on maybe that's what
you're saying media Savvy yeah proves my
point you're dumb Laura you're not gonna
be on anymore this is one of the things
I've said repeatedly when people talk
about BLM for example they act as if
this is an organization that speaks for
black people I don't remember any focus
group going into black neighborhoods and
asking them what kind of political
change they'd like to see and then
forming an organization around it sounds
to me like there were people who also
had black skin who claim that they speak
for every other black person and started
pushing far left Marxist talking points
do you know what what incidents started
BLM uh I believe it was Trayvon Martin
correct yes it wasn't George Floyd
people think it was it was and uh as you
know George Zimmerman was found not
guilty of shooting and killing Trayvon
Martin uh there were no blacks on the
jury but um there was a black juror and
the those jurors who spoke publicly
afterwards said that race never came up
and the blacks draw or said alternate
said that he would have found him not
guilty as well and race never came up
what's interesting to me about the
George Floyd riots the four months we
had in 2020.
is that the lead prosecutor in the case
was a black man and I'm a try I was a
lawyer I was a trial lawyer when I
practiced law and the most important
part of a trial is your opening
statement and he took pains to say that
the police in general were not on trial
the Minneapolis PD in general is not on
trial this individual named Derek
Sherman was on trial for what he did or
what he didn't do he never even implied
what he did had to do with race and
children was never charged with a hate
crime yet you had four months of people
in the streets why because the
Assumption was because of what what
Chauvin did had to do with George
Floyd's race even though the prosecutor
never even implied it yeah that's what
was that all about well also I want to
mention this at the end they were saying
you know this was obviously racially
motivated which yeah which is nonsense
but in the I remember with the Trayvon
story NBC actually came out and they had
to apologize for this later which was
just shocking that any media Outlet was
willing to do that maybe it's because
this was about 10 years ago and they
wouldn't do it today but they edited the
recording of the call that Zimmerman
made to the police they asked him to
describe Zimmerman and he said he looked
like he was up to no good and then they
asked him to describe what he was
wearing and he said something like he's
wearing a hoodie it's black and they
sliced the phone call down so they said
how does he look and he responds in the
edited tape he looks like he's up to no
good he looks black
that's evil it is evil that's evil and
that is why people are deluded um
there's a website called policemag.com
and they asked people who are
self-described as very liberal how many
unarmed black men did the police kill in
half of them thought the police killed
one thousand eight percent thought to
kill ten thousand and then people who
were self-described as liberal 39 of
them thought the police killed 1 000
unarmed black men in 2019 and five
percent thought they killed ten thousand
the answer was twelve according to the
Washington Post database yeah that's how
deluded people are between what's really
going on what they think is going on in
fact the police kill more unarmed whites
every year than they kill unarmed blacks
I bet most people in this audience could
probably not name an unarmed white
person because media doesn't give a rip
well and not only that but when you
actually look at that uh post that was
published on the number of black men who
were killed by the police while not
being armed and you go through the
specific cases one of them was he was
attacking the police officer okay so and
there were others like attacking an old
lady just because you're unarmed doesn't
mean you're not a threat to somebody
else Michael Brown was unarmed his DNA
found on them on the officer's gun he
reached for it yeah and uh there's a guy
in the famous case named uh Amadou
Diablo Diablo uh in New York I think I'm
mispronouncing his name an immigrant and
he fit the description of somebody and
they had him in some sort of alley they
told him to show his hand show his hands
and he reaches 4 his wallet and they
shoot him uh Hillary referred to the
cops as murderers they were found not
guilty because the gesture was recently
perceived as a threatening gesture so
you were unarmed it doesn't mean you
were in that dangerous or not recently
perceived as dangerous there's a reason
they say hands up you are not supposed
to reach for anything when the pl when
anyone has a gun point when a police
officer at a gun point out you're there
telling you you're under arrest whatever
it is they don't even have to have the
gun drawn do not reach into your pockets
this don't reach into your glove box
this is one of the most basic things and
all the time we hear people saying oh
well you know as a black person with
children I constantly have to tell them
when the cops pull you over don't reach
into your wallet don't reach in your
glove box
that's not a black or white thing that
everyone knows that your parents should
teach you how to properly behave at a
traffic stop Hillary refer to that as
the talk meaning only black people say
that no not yes it's getting people
killed because it's called The George
Floyd effect or the Ferguson effect and
that's the phenomenon of cops pulling
back from their normal proactive
policing so the last few years there are
thousands of people who are dead or who
have been injured who otherwise would
not have suffered hit the police have
been doing their normal proactive
policing and the so-called excess
casualties or deaths are the very black
and brown on people that people on the
left purport to care about yeah so
you're getting people killed because
they're keeping accurate information
from them because I think that's the
biggest crime it's sad too because I'm
from Minnesota and uh like the the North
Minneapolis Police for a lot of years
not the not a great reputation there is
a a strong argument to be made that
changes needed to happen that there were
problems within that police force that
are well documented that go back decades
and decades and decades but what it does
is it takes the focus off the actual
problem and puts it on to one individual
example which when misreported or
reported the way that it was brings
people and makes them extremely
radicalizes people to the point where
like you said we we experienced a lot of
rioting I'll give you another example
Brett we know about the the subway guy
Daniel Penny who put the choke hold on
Jordan Neely three weeks earlier tell me
if you knew this three weeks earlier
Tulsa Oklahoma homeless black man walks
up behind a white guy AI takes out a gun
shoots him in the back of the head kills
him goes to another area of Tulsa
Oklahoma finds another white guy shoots
him in the back of the head and kills
him admits he did it because they were
white oh my gosh uh can you can you
imagine if the races were reversed it
just had been a white guy homeless pop
two black guys behind the head execution
style and killed him we know cities
might have been burnt down you know his
name we know the name of the people who
are victimized most people don't even
know about this story it took place
three weeks earlier than the internet on
the subject and I had heard about the
story and watched it not get picked up
what I also found was interesting with
Jordan Neely was that the fact that he
had a history of specifically committing
assaults in subways yeah so he acted
like he was just you know obviously he's
troubled there is a lot of a reasonable
conversation to have around the Foster
system which he was involved in mental
health things like that but we should
not deny the fact that he had
established criminal history
specifically in the place where uh this
this interaction with Penny happened
right and Hannah Claire real quickly
what's interesting about this is what is
the evidence
that Daniel Penny would have just sat
there had uh Jordan England white okay
white guys threatening people it's cool
he's white what up bro it's all good
really yeah it would have done nothing
the guy had been white it's ridiculous
he was screaming that he wasn't afraid
to go back to jail that he was going to
hurt people right Hannah Claire you made
this point about examining the person's
past this is one of the things that
drives me crazy every single time
someone commits a senseless act of
violence the left bends over backwards
to engage in every single facet of
socioeconomic analysis to find an excuse
for this person this is because we
didn't fund the public school they went
to this is because we're not building
enough libraries this because of some
form of structural racism but when a man
sees an unhinged person screaming on the
subway threatening your average person
and he does something which is totally
understandable and even heroic by
intervening to help people the only way
we can understand that is as racism now
socioeconomic factors and the
circumstances totally melt away and this
is a war between good and evil and those
are the only factors to consider and of
course he was Pure Evil never never mind
the fact that uh Jordan Neely had
assaulted a six-year-old woman broken
her jaw also that he had been given an
opportunity to go into rehab to get uh
city services and counseling and he left
that program well he attempted to kidnap
a child there are all kinds of things
it's insane it just doesn't make sense
at all and again I want to have
compassion I want to understand but I
can't do that at the expense of logic or
uh inaccurate information and it's a and
you pointed out something important
you're talking about compassion you are
compassionate saying that we should
allow people to commit crimes as a false
compassion right Mercy for the pedophile
is actually cruelty against the child
Mercy towards the thief is actually
cruelty against the person they might
steal from really Mercy isn't even the
right word for it Mercy is a good thing
there's a difference between mercy and
licentiousness or leniency people have
to be punished for crimes if you don't
punish them you hurt the people around
them and you hurt them too because they
need to be held accountable plus this is
the least racist majority white country
in the world racism has never been a
less important factor than American Life
today uh this is the only majority white
company country that that elected a
black president yep I mean honestly how
much more do you need the president of
Harvard is a black female we've had
black CEOs black CEO of McDonald's black
CEO of of uh of uh Time Warner black
CEOs of American Express there there are
three major big three biggest cities in
America New York L.A Chicago all have
black Mayors uh Chicago's second
consecutive black mayor even though the
city's just the third black New York is
25 black second uh black mayor LA's nine
percent black they go to black female
mayor uh you know Forbes had a list of
the most influential uh celebrities 25
of them were black we can go on and on
and on it's never been a less important
factor uh exception for interracial
marriage all-time high what more do you
need what more do you need they need a
couple more Mansions over there at BLM
right the people who are grifting off of
this need to make more money the
politicians 500 at least fake hate crime
the last few years because they we've
got a supply and demand problem that's
right that's exactly demand for racism
uh is exceeding the supply so they make
up stuff you can always tell because
they never know how to draw the swastika
they draw it wrong everything's true
it's always it's always uh it's always
that you know how to draw the swastika
bread it's kind of frightening yeah
we're all concerned about you now I will
say like when you mentioned earlier you
were mentioning the statistics about
um what they said was like is racism a
very big problem here in America and
then do they experience it in their
daily lives and you said when they say
they don't experience it as much in
their daily lives 89 said little or
nothing the reason I think that is
inherently is that we live in our phones
now and you're carrying around a device
that's telling you that the world is
evil and that the people around you are
evil so they're not reacting to the
world around them as they experience it
they're reacting to the world around
them as they experience it through their
phone and through data that they're
reading uh through stories that they're
reading through infographics to things
they're seeing on Tick Tock they're not
actually responding to the way they
experience the world I mean look at
Barack Obama he goes to the finest
school in the state of Hawaii then he
goes to Occidental which is a very elite
private school in La for two years then
he goes to Colombia finishes up there
then he goes to Harvard becomes
president of the Harvard Law review then
he goes to work for a major Law Firm his
kids all went to private school and he's
Malcolm X I mean what is that what is
that yeah yeah it doesn't make any sense
it's offensive well it is offensive this
is something it's almost like kind of
the the rich kids syndrome right no one
ever wants to admit that they had a good
upbringing no one ever wants to admit
that their parents worked hard and that
they had things handed to them look I am
extremely blessed the the privilege that
I had in life is that I had two parents
who loved me tremendously who stayed
together who cared a lot about me and my
siblings and that did give me a leg up
now here's the problem I'm not ashamed
of that and I shouldn't be I think
everyone should have that leg up this is
why we need to do everything we can to
combat fatherlessness in the incentive
structure that the state has traded to
promote anybody born in America who was
born with two parents hit the lottery
twice that's right a black kid who's
poor with Mom and Dad in the house will
have a better outcome than a middle
class white kid was just a mom wow and
the surprise number one issue in America
is the epidemic of fatherlessness 70 of
black kids today you know the world
without a father in the home married to
the mother up from 25 back in 1965. now
25 of white kids entered the world
without a father in the home married to
the mother and 65 is important because
that's when a guy named Daniel Patrick
Moynihan he was then the assistant
Secretary of Labor wrote A booklet for
his boss called The Negro family a case
for National Action at the time 25 as I
mentioned the black kids were born
outside of wedlock which he thought was
horrific and we needed to do something
about it now it's almost three times
that and what we've done with the
welfare estate is incentivized women to
marry the government and incentivize men
to abandon their financial and more
responsibility that's right well and
there's an additional element here too I
totally agree with you on the welfare
state but the Brookings Institute
released a very interesting paper where
they basically said that while
conservatives tend to look at the
welfare state another massively
overlooked part of this was Roe v Wade
and the fact that the social
expectations completely changed now if a
woman was pregnant it wasn't on the man
to stay with her it was on her to choose
whether or not she was going to get an
abortion and so that that reshaped the
way we thought about fatherlessness if
you got a woman pregnant and didn't take
care of that child and any Community you
were entirely detested you destroyed
your reputation you had to get out of
town nowadays that's just the choice
that you happen to make the mother might
have issues with it but she could have
gotten an abortion right and studies
bear out that having a father in the
home is the is the biggest factor in
children no question about it five times
more likely to be poor uh and commit
crime nine times more likely to drop out
of school 20 times more likely to end up
in jail Obama even quoted those stats
once yeah and children who are raised by
a single father I say it on the black
face but Obama can say and he's down
with the breath it's just crazy how many
like Black and Hispanic white
supremacists there are there's so much
diversity in white supremacy diversity
Equity inclusion I think it's like the
white Supreme like the cake I guess as a
Dei person now ensuring that of the yeah
well that's very Progressive also though
think about colleges that incentivize
like somebody pointed out they're like
uh hard luck story beats 4.0 GPA every
time right at colleges so you're
incentivized even when you come from
that background because that's part of
affirmative action programs in Scott
scholarships those stories often will be
I was raised by a single mother and
that's that was hard for me and I
overcame it whatever else but actually
studies show that children raised by in
father-only homes where their mother has
abandoned them outperform single mother
like it is the single biggest difference
in the entire world and yet what are we
uh you were talking about this at the
Barbie movie it we are a gracing
anti-patriarchy that's right bananas and
black lives matter on their website
attack the nuclear impact family that's
right and by the way Barack Obama
Embrace black lives matter his first
book was all about how he had angst
because he didn't have a relationship
with his biological dad Barack Obama
well and yeah that's exactly right so
whenever people talk about patriarchy
what they're really talking about what
patriarchy is is the headship of the
father and the household the idea that
this is denigrated the idea that this is
slam the idea that this is smeared it's
obvious why right Marx wanted to destroy
the family these people also want to be
free to pursue whatever deranged uh
perverted sexual appetites they have and
family gets in the way of that but here
we are and the co-founders of BLM are
self-described train marxists off the
website Midway through 2020 because
people kept quoting that to them and
showing the old video of them where they
talked about that at a meeting right
well people have lost faith in God and
so they have to end up uh pledging uh
Allegiance and giving their souls to
things that are of course significantly
less important than one's faith and
one's values we have a poll here from
Gallup which actually shows belief in
five Supernatural entities edges down to
new lows well first they don't even like
that framing Supernatural entities uh
they're talking about God angels heaven
they bleep out the censor out the word
hell and also the devil yes so so belief
in God has etched downward you you see
this the trend over the past 20 years or
so it was interesting because as I was
reading this article one thing that
really uh was depressing to me was the
fact that they were listing the
discrepancy between Catholics and
Protestants and the number of Catholics
and Protestants who believe in God why
would it not be 100 for both groups but
you can identify
there is a cultural element to
Christianity especially people who say
oh I would I was always Protestant but I
actually do nothing about it I don't
read the Bible I go to church when I'm
made to go to church they don't live it
but they will claim the identity I think
that can be attributed to a little bit
of this I think it parallels the decline
in people that uh feel patriotic and
feel feel proud of America absolutely
and if you look at the trend lines that
they parallel and and fatherlessness too
because I you know there's a reason he
is described as God the Father uh there
are many reasons for it but a person's
relationship with their father is going
to inform their attitudes towards God
very heavily in fact statistically we
know one of the number one predictors of
a child choosing to stay with their
religion other family is whether their
dad practices that faith if the mom
practices that Faith they're likely to
some degree to stay in but not nearly as
likely as if their dad practices the
faith it's incredibly important kids
learn about God by the way that their
fathers act and it's something that we
don't really account for or consider God
and how to live I mean exactly and learn
all sorts of things to their parents and
the the decisions that you make in your
life and when you become a parent should
be cognitive the fact that someone is
now watching you someone is looking up
to you and I think so much of our
anti-responsibility culture parallels
this right like I don't want to think
about God because I don't want to think
about the afterlife because I don't want
to have to think about the fact that my
decisions have consequences in 30 years
of being on radio I've invited Jesse
Jackson on dozens of times he won't even
respond I invited I'll sharpen on dozens
of times won't respond uh Maxine wardens
won't respond uh Louis Farrakhan
wouldn't respond but one of these
so-called black leaders um fume at the
time he was head of the NAACP president
he was in Congress in Maryland now he's
back in Congress in Maryland and he did
come on the show and my first question
was as follow Mr mfume as between the
presence of white racism or the absence
of black fathers which poses a bigger
threat to the black community without
missing a beat to his credit he said the
absence of black father good for him
yeah yeah I mean it's undeniable and
you're right it is to his credit because
the entire left-wing establishment is
going to punish anyone who says
something like that but it's just so
undeniably true yeah I was just
wondering if I could ask you're listing
this uh this band of people who don't
want to speak to you presumably because
your conservative or republican uh can
you tell us a little about how about how
you got to this this place politically
I mean how I became conservative yeah
when did you adopt the title a
republican uh well I my mom was a
Democrat my dad was a Republican and
they would have these very interesting
uh disputes across the dinner table
nobody called anybody a fascist nobody
called anybody a Nazi nobody said you
only care about the the rich you don't
care about the poor and so as a kid you
identify with your mom and so I was a
democrat in fact the first person I
voted for for president was Jimmy Carter
and that was because he uh uh uh forward
pardon Nixon and I thought that was
inappropriate I now think it was a smart
thing to do and so I punished uh uh him
for doing that and so I voted for Jimmy
Carter but from that point on I voted
Republican he punished the American
people if you held Carter get elected I
was an independent for years and then I
decided to run uh against uh Barbara
Boxer I forget the year but a bunch of
people prevailed upon me to do that and
so I switched my affiliation from
independent to Republican and then I
flew to DC to interview with a bunch of
uh Republican Senators to see if I can
get the nomination get the endorsement
during the primary season if they had
endorsed me I was going to run they
endorsed Carly fiorina instead of me so
I decided not to run and by the way when
I found out that they endorsed her I
said why they said three reasons she's a
woman I said I'll give you that I'm not
gonna have a sex change operation to run
for Santa she has more money than you do
she did because she just uh resigned
from Hewlett-Packard they gave her a big
settlement the third reason was she has
higher name recognition than you do I
said no she doesn't maybe she does in DC
but not in California I had a 30 name
recognition her apartment Box's first
two opponents a guy named Bruce
Hutchinson and then a guy named Matt
Fong at the same juncture had a five
percent name recognition and Carly
fiorina lost by 10 points and put very
little by the way of her own money into
the campaign yeah uh long answer to your
question that's when I became a
registered Republican but I've always
been a small ill libertarian well I was
going to say if if you were identified
as a potential candidate to run for
office as a republican they must have
been aware that you were toying with
conservative ideas was that something
you got a lot of pushback for and uh did
you resist staying independent to resist
the label of Republican I think so
because I always feel both parties still
spend and I still do one of the things
I'm proposing is an amendment to the
Constitution to fix spending to a
certain percentage of the GDP that's
great with exceptions for war and for
natural disaster other than that they
both spend and um part of it is because
the so-called entitlements programs are
on automatic pilot uh Social Security
Medicare Medicaid Obamacare and a few
others and if you even suggest you're
going to reform them and try to run for
office you're going to lose well you
know so so the can gets kicked down the
road even Barack Obama and Bill Clinton
use the word unsustainable to describe
the entitlements program so everybody
knows that they're unsustainable you
just can't politically do anything they
don't want to ask them no and if but
however if you're forced to do it by law
then then and only then will there be a
reform for young people like you they're
not going to be there uh and so it seems
to me the president and I will do that
when I become president would use the
bully pulpit to explain this to people
particularly young voters that this is
in your best interest and maybe
something can happen and so what I just
want to ask quickly uh where would you
fix that uh GDP to Reverend
which is half of what uh it's it's it is
at right now all right it's going to
require massive massive changes yeah uh
and um I say 10 because in 1900 at all
three levels State local and federal
Believe It or Not government took nine
percent from the American people now all
three levels government takes 32 percent
and in my opinion if you put a cost to
the mandates government takes almost 50
percent this is way way bigger than what
the founding fathers intended they did
not intend for there to be an income tax
they intended for The Limited duties and
obligations of the federal government to
be paid for by duties and tariffs they
would be appalled at Obamacare they'd be
appalled at Social Security they'd be
appalled at Medicare they'd be appalled
at FEMA they'd be appalled at the things
that the federal government is doing
well it's interesting you point out that
the federal government takes so much of
our money and they have and you're right
there but there's a an interesting
observation this is referred to as
Hauser's law I'm not sure if you're
familiar with this but the basic idea is
that regardless of where tax rates are
regardless of how much the government
tries to take since World War II Federal
revenues have always hovered around 19.5
percent which just goes to show that if
you you impose these insanely high taxes
on people they either become less
productive and so there's less attacks
or they start hiding their money so the
government can't get to it rich people
are not rich because they're stupid yeah
that's right they hide their money or
they put them in other other kinds of
things so that they're taxed less yeah
and so you know there are certain
left-wing commentators who will scoff at
the idea of the Laffer Curve and a more
sophisticated left-wing approach is to
say okay the Laffer Curve exists but I
don't think the parabola Peaks until
we're at 70 percent in terms of our tax
rate all right well that's ridiculous
but at least you're acknowledging the
reality that if you tax people uh at
zero percent you'll have zero Revenue if
you text them at 100 you'll also have
zero Revenue because no one's going to
work and there's some point along the
Middle where you maximize uh revenue for
the government but it's also very
valuable for us to have this empirical
data that shows us you don't seem to be
able to get past 20 on the federal level
in terms of what you're taking in so why
aren't they adjusting the way they tax
us so that we can keep more of our money
since their revenue pretty much won't
shift from there that's a great point we
were talking earlier about the ignorance
between how many unarmed black men are
killed versus what people think same
thing with taxes I was at a party a few
years ago a buddy of mine was
celebrating his birthday he's a Vietnam
vet I assumed everybody at the party was
conservative thinking like I think
there's a woman and she started
complaining she started complaining tell
me about it it's always somebody uh she
was complaining about how rich people
didn't pay very much in taxes I thought
she was joking At first she kept saying
it over and over again I said excuse me
I overheard you say rich people don't
pay their taxes I said I'm probably one
of the so-called Rich if you find
somebody making above 350 000 or more as
in the top one percent
I said I have my 1040 in the car would
you like to see it she said no I said of
all the federal taxes what percentage do
you think it's paid by the rich he said
what do you mean I said soon this pie is
all the federal taxes what slice by
percentage is paid by the top one
percent or I see what you mean one
percent
she said maybe two percent oh my gosh
and and Shameless I kept waiting for her
to ask me what the answer was because he
saw my face I looked at Paul like you
did
and she never asked she didn't want to
know and the numbers the number is 40
yeah while taking in 15 to 20 of the
nation's income so if anything rich
people are over taxed not under under
taxed she doesn't want to hear that no
when you look at income tax I think it's
what the top 10 pays 90 percent of the
income taxes and the bottom 50 pay by
four percent they pay almost nothing
the best part of that story is that
you're driving around here look I'll
show you ticked off yeah listening for
these kind of complaints like when can I
I'm in California when you put in the
state income tax uh sales tax property
taxes it is not uncommon for somebody
with regular income as opposed to
capital gains income being taxed at 60
yeah even Bill Maher complained about it
one time and this is part of lost Bill
Maher then you're then you're probably
over taxing people and and someone who
runs a business myself when you have to
cut that money out of your own bank
account rather than having your employer
withhold it from you you start seeing
taxes in a little bit of a different way
this is one of these reforms that I know
there are probably implications to this
that I'm not really exploring by so
haphazardly suggesting we do this but
I'm often tempted to say we should make
every American person pay their taxes
that way no one should have their taxes
upheld by their employer you should have
to pay it in a lump sum so that you see
what they're taking for you I heard
Milton Friedman say it was a huge
mistake that we have automatic
withholding like the people really saw
what they were what they were being
charged for taxes we would have changes
yeah absolutely I think that's true I
think that's one of the problems some of
our systems uh insulate people or they
keep people from the realities of what
they do I say I I this is one of my
favorite tangents of all time but I
really think that we need to breed a
culture of responsibility and long-term
thinking I think there are reasons why
this this tax withholding is it seems
nice and somebody else deals with it but
ultimately you vote very differently
when you're well informed this is a
theme we keep coming back tonight when
when you're talking to this woman at a
dinner party and she says I don't want
to know it's because that way she
doesn't have to change her opinion she
doesn't have to evolve her worldview
based on accurate information and being
well informed brings us to the disaster
that we call public education in the
inner city 13 public high schools zero
percent of the kids can do math at grade
level zero another half a dozen were six
percent can excuse me another half dozen
one percent can because half of all the
public high schools in Baltimore all
located in the inner city we the kids
are one percent or zero percent math
proficient it's Chicago 53 schools zero
percent are mass proficient if you can't
and 85 percent of blacks uh in the
eighth grade these are 13 year old kids
can either do math nor read a grade
level and half of them can't do basic
reading which means you cannot
critically think yeah and you can be
manipulated by emotion so scary it is
scary I'll mention this my father was a
public school teacher on the south side
of Chicago and for his entire career he
taught and then towards the end of his
career he became a vice principal and
then eventually principal and one thing
he would talk about was the fact that
when they as the high school would get
these students from their middle schools
they were so unbelievably far behind
that the best they could hope to get
them to do was still significantly below
where they should be it's it's a very
sad State of Affairs
teaching to the curve yes and as a
result everybody else suffers that's
right why we've got to have vouchers
yeah agreed yeah I was gonna say I was
about to ask but what are some solutions
to this well uh yeah vouchers but by by
far um there was a study done some years
ago where government School teachers
which is a term I prefer rather than
public school teachers government School
teachers were asked where you send your
own school age kids Nationwide 10 of us
send our kids to private school six
percent of black families do 49 of
Philadelphia governments will teach you
the school age kids with their own kids
in private school what a shock which
shows you the people who know the
schools the best teachers aren't putting
their own kids in it what does that tell
you when you see how sausages are made
you don't want to feed them to your kid
I guess the CEO of McDonald's does not
let his kid eat McDonald's the the
people who run social media companies do
not allow their kids to have smartphones
they CEO McDonald's
but it's good for you good enough for
your kids yes yeah exactly and that's
that's one of the massive problems with
this country today we think about what
is best for our own families which is of
course what we should be doing but we
don't extend that and say well maybe I
shouldn't be doing things that would
actively harm somebody else's family
maybe I should actually care about the
people around me I should care about my
country I should care about the national
project yeah I think that's true I think
that there is a importance on on
emphasizing nuclear family in your
decisions but the nuclear family is a
building block in a larger sphere right
so you have your family who's a part of
a community and you make choices for
your family but hopefully they
positively benefit your community and
your community then benefits absolutely
you know stay and goes on and on and on
I think it's a mistake to assume that
people aren't seeing the consequences of
that I just think that you know I I knew
someone who when she had her first baby
you know you have to immediately make a
pediatrician appointment there's all
kinds of things you have to do and so
she asked the nurse in the room who she
had a positive experience with where do
you take your kids I want to go wherever
you're taking your kids because you were
kind to me and I know you love your kid
you seem like a devoted mom and I need
help and I think that's what the culture
reads Mutual assistants by knowing that
someone who makes good decisions for
their own family can recommend and give
you advice and guidance when you start
your own Anna Claire there was an
article in the Atlantic which is a
left-wing publication a few months ago
yeah it talked about all the different
decisions that a young family makes when
they're having a baby and they said the
most important decision is whether or
not you're able to move into a
neighborhood where there are a lot of
two-parent households even if you move
into one and you're a single parent
household you're going to benefit by the
culture and the reverse of course is
true too you move into a neighborhood
where a whole bunch of single parent
single parent household is going to
corrupt the culture yeah yeah even just
think about like I need somebody to
babysit my child I don't have anyone to
babysit my child if you're in a
neighborhood with a lot of single parent
households that parents is at work that
kid is probably got a lot of daycare by
themselves you're not going to have the
community that you can rely upon to call
on and I think that that's part of the
culture in America has shifted away from
that I feel especially in cities right
everyone's bunched up close together but
there's not the same level of connection
that you have if you live in an area
where it's households on a block I mean
that's how it was I grew up in a
cul-de-sac right uh we knew our
neighbors we knew all the people that
lived on that side I didn't know what a
cul-de-sac was
it was called a court but we call it
yeah
and and you're right uh you know you
watch Leave it to Beaver yeah you guys
are familiar with that oh yeah uh and
there's a dispute between the boys and
the parents would resolve it the father
would talk about it they're no fathers
that's right no one can say my dad can
beat up your dad anymore because there's
no dads around well here's another
element of this you're absolutely right
what has happened in media over the past
50 years is progressively we have
portrayed fathers uh in a worse and
worse light so whereas in Leave it to
Beaver you had a father who was strong
he was masculine he was intelligent he
was solving problems for his family you
now have the standard Homer Simpson
character portraying fathers and
television shows don't get me wrong I
love The Simpsons I think it's a
hilarious show but this is a really
negative cultural shift and I believe
the reason for this is because when you
want to attack an institution you attack
the leader and the father's the head of
the household I got a question for you
guys since you bring this up I was
talking to a buddy of mine uh that I
work with when I was doing my Epic Times
TV show and I said you notice that on
commercials the the doofus is always
white guy oh always and and he says I
never noticed that I said I said look at
the commercials the the smart knowing
guy is always a black guy but the doofus
is always a white guy look at the
commercials that Snoop Dogg is doing
with what's that what's a guy with the
comedian's name I'm not sure Corona beer
commercials
yeah and so Snoop is sitting on the
beach and Sandberg here and Snoop is the
all-knowing guy and Samberg the doof it
happens I never noticed so he looks at
TV comes back every week he said you're
right it's everything also the woman is
always a genius and the man's an idiot
does it bother you guys I'm just
wondering as a white person it bothers
me a lot there is no because I'm not
racist yeah no it bothers me because I
also feel like we wouldn't like it for
anyone else right I don't like it for
white people just like I wouldn't want
it for anyone there was a crime show and
I wish I could remember the name maybe
it's 24 uh and my brother you know we
were all home it was around Christmas
time I was in college he was like you
guys gotta watch the show it'll be so
fun we'll all watch it while we wrap
presents or do whatever and after the
first two I was like hey I can play this
game with you I bet that I bet the
villain is a white man I bet the villain
I think of mine is a white man yeah
that's the white man and that is true
all over the place and the thing is like
I understand that the especially with
crime shows there is maybe a discomfort
in talking about race it's not that we
should harp on anything specifically but
when you see uh the same person being
made the villain all the time that's
disingenuine too well the truth is that
60 of the robberies the homicides and
shootings are done by black people in
America the guy that does that show Cops
he said I undershow black crime because
I don't want to push the stereotype and
it over shows white crime there was also
a study done some years ago that looked
at the number of people in late night
television who were doctors and lawyers
and the numbers of blacks were over
represented the number of criminals were
underrepresented yeah oh well they
always want to sort of go against the
grain with the stereotypes and you know
you made this point about white people
being overrepresented in these
television shows when they portray crime
on the one hand you can imagine them
saying yes I wanted to fight this
stereotype yes I want to show fewer
black criminals but then it comes at the
expense of white people now you're
making it seem as if white people are
more criminal than the statistics show
that they are and in terms of this
question of
commercials showing white men as idiots
and then black men or black women is
brilliant in knowing everything that's
certainly uh annoys me it's something
that you just get to a point where you
don't even think about it because it's
so common what bothers me even more than
that are the commercials and that does
bother me a lot but what bothers me even
more are the commercials where the
father's an idiot and the mother's a
genius because now you're actually
subverting the family unit itself you
are denigrating the relationship between
men and women I think when you create
racial struggles that's a serious
problem I hate when people in power do
that but there is no greater modern
attack than the attack on the family
mm-hmm I think the family structure is
uh really integral to everything that we
do and in some way some things we're
talking about remind me of um this is a
second I wish I could remember who put
it out right now right now but that
there is a slight Trend towards uh
becoming more religious among uh gen Z
but they are they are it's not that they
are dominantly religious but they are
just starting to go back to church they
are starting to embrace religion away
and uh again especially since we let off
with this uh idea that fewer people
believe in God even people who claim to
be Protestants or Catholics yeah uh it
is interesting that as we watch the
family structure for everybody get
destroyed there is a return to search
for guidance for for fund Health meeting
for core values I think that's one of
the things that I'm actually hopeful
about in this country I think there is a
desire to find a common value and
re-establish who we are even when we are
different what we cherish and what we as
neighbors know we can expect from our
neighbors yeah well so speaking of some
of the issues that we see with respect
to the attack on the family this idea
yeah that men are idiots the idea that
we're a horribly sexist country I want
to highlight a story from a part of the
world where women actually are genuinely
treated like garbage in the left almost
never seems to do anything to try to
stand up for them uh beauty salon banned
in Afghanistan is a blow to women's
Financial Freedom so this is basically a
story about how in Afghanistan now that
the Taliban are in charge they have
officially banned beauty salons for
women they're shutting down businesses
that these women have spent their their
lives building we have a story of a 34
year old mother
of two who's not going to have her
business anymore it really is a a sad
story I think as you know an evil Pro
man Pro patriarchy person who thinks
that anything that's bad for women is
bad for men and anything that's bad for
men is bad for women I gotta say you
know I hold very strongly to Traditional
Values I don't think there's anything
against traditional uh values or
traditional sensibilities of wanting
women to be able to go to beauty salons
something like this is just so horrible
and senseless but of course the only
time the left really wants to talk about
the condition of women living under
Theocratic Islamic regimes is when they
want to compare themselves to someone
because politics in America didn't go
their way they can't even go to school
yeah where's the squad where's the Elon
Omar yep where's LLC
about this today this is Ayanna Presley
where are they they're nowhere and it's
because there's no consistency in their
logic right I mean so we're going to
point out in this article that without
these beauty salons which are women only
anyways because of the culture and uh
the Theocratic role in Afghanistan there
are no places where women can publicly
assemble without a male chaperone like
they can be in their homes and that's it
and women in America believe they are
oppressed I mean I just I just find it
deeply ironic and in some ways
insensitive right the next time they're
saying you know we're with her I want to
ask you who is her this is terrible
grammar this is relativism because in a
lot of ways what it is is there you're
told here in America because we focus so
much on ideological bounds that are on
Race sexuality and gender is that stay
in your lane you can't comment on what's
going on there because you inherently
can't understand their culture and a lot
of the people that believe that I
haven't traveled the world they haven't
been outside the US they have no frame
of reference outside of that so you're
just instead of having the uncomfortable
conversation that you might want to
criticize something about somebody who
might not look like you or might not be
from the same place as you the idea is
to just push the can down the road and
ignore it pretend like it's not
happening and Hannah Claire this whole
business about women in America being
oppressed is laughable every every year
hear that woman that Obama was in office
he would come out and talk about how
women make X number of sense on the
dollar compared to men so if that were
true you would fire all your men hire
women and pocket the difference uh there
are more women now in college than men
the numbers of women entering medical
school and law school equal the number
of of men graduation stats too right
graduation stats women live longer I
mean it 90 of the people behind bars are
men I mean yeah where how where are they
oppressed this is the only uh instance
in history that I'm familiar with of an
oppressed class being more likely to win
custody battles being more likely to
receive more lenient sentences crimes
more likely to vote more likely to
receive a higher education more likely
to be considered for uh Elite programs
such as being admitted into a stem field
based on their application it's really
man a difficult kind of impression
that's a pressure peel me off some of
that yeah exactly exactly
even so right what we have to consider
is because of the the sexual Revolution
and modern feminism and basically the
way I've described feminism in the past
is it's it's essentially especially in
the west
um a PR campaign for the sexual
Revolution to try to get women to
co-sign their own uh debasement into
basing
what we've done is we've reduced women
to objects in a different way where now
all you exist to do is be sexually
appealing to men and once you've done
that and a human person is just a thing
and their value is merely a product of
what they can give you and a woman is
just a sexual object well once a man
through surgical intervention can
emulate the secondary sex
characteristics of Womanhood that you
find appealing now he can be a woman too
I mean we lose everything and Sheamus I
think it's also driven by power and by
politics if the left convinces women
that they are oppressed the same thing
as convincing blacks that they're that
they're still subject second-class
citizens yeah it's the same kind of
thing we are the party wearing the white
hat uh and social justice for women and
for minorities and these guys over here
these National Republicans they were the
Black Cat
the meme it says like uh it says
Republicans are racist Republicans if
they got to pick the Supreme Court it's
just all Clarence Thomas it's just a
bunch of clearance houses it's it's also
like for for this topic I think it's a
lot to do with with when you take the
when you divide the men and women that
way you make them when you make it the
woman an object you are now inherently
stopping the family from forming right
so that you start it's just Marxism it
just it just ends up dividing the family
further it makes us enemies right like I
don't want to live in a world where I
don't believe I can live a happy life
alongside man hopefully with the man
when I'm married you know what I mean
like I want to believe that we are meant
to be uh complementary and to build each
other up through our unique strengths I
don't think that that is the culture
that uh aggressive left tells us and I
think that's inherently destructive
right so not only are we destroying the
family by separating kids from the
parents but we are separating men from
women saying you guys are actually
enemies right especially if you're a man
you are the problem and you should eat
yourself that's that's Benny uh Thompson
who is the chair of the so-called
January 6 Insurrection committee she's
publicly referred to Clarence Thomas as
an Uncle Tom it's unbelievable it's
unbelievable you know it's so disgusting
this rhetoric that you hear when when
people try to pile on somebody because
they have the wrong opinion they belong
to some kind of minority group as
happens to you it happens that basically
anyone else who speaks out against the
left from the vantage point of someone
in a group that they quote unquote
represent they end up being tarred and
feathered and what's so particularly
heinous about it is
you know if if somebody tells you as a
member of the out group that they don't
like you so like if a white person says
something bad to a black person or a
black person says something bad to a
white person that's bad but at the very
least there hasn't been this narrative
created that like your own in-group is
rejecting you your own family your own
friends people in your community are
rejecting you to tell someone like you
are actually you actually don't fit in
with the category that you're a part of
it's a far worse way of slurring to
Spanish from the village we were talking
about Thomas Soul earlier oh he's
incredible there's a magazine called
Ebony magazine it comes out once a month
it's not nearly the got the cloud it
used to have but virtually every black
family had it on the coffee table we did
for decades and every year they'd have a
feature called the 100 most influential
black Americans and every year absent
from that list Thomas Soul Walter
Williams and even Clarence Thomas how is
that possible Thomas Soul has written
about 40 books uh David Mamet the
playwright referred to Thomas sold as
America's greatest contemporary
philosopher Walter Williams is the first
to my knowledge only a chair of an
economics Department of a
non-historically black College written a
number of books both Thomas so and he
have had hundreds of outlets in their
syndicated column and most black people
don't know who the hell they are because
they've been banished from the village
can I ask how did your Republican father
respond to this did he point this out to
you was this a conversation you had at
home no and this this is just something
that I that I observe my Republican
father said this about the Democrats
Democrats want to give you something for
nothing when you're trying to get
something for nothing you almost always
end up getting nothing for something one
of his favorite speaking of which
Speaking of which in order for me to
qualify for that next debate yes next
month in August 23rd is the debate I
need to have donations from 40 000
individuals you can donate as little as
one dollar just go to my website Larry
elderforpresident.com or larryelder.com
one dollar this vast audience one dollar
even if you want somebody else talk
about the kinds of things we're talking
about the epidemic of fatherlessness the
lie that America systemically raises the
need for an amendment to fix spending to
a certain percentage of the GDP school
choice I even have a proposed
legislation to get rid of these soft on
crime George Soros back the age that's
great and that's on my website
larryolder.com so even if you want
somebody else to put those issues front
and center have me up there hold my beer
so just one dollar and it's just one
dollar they only have to donate one
dollar that's gonna help you get on
stage 40 000 individual donations what
kind of debate do you want guys we want
an interesting debate yeah yeah the
great eldersky up there or what the
black face of white supremacy In the
Flesh I had to I send it good season
form I sent that article to somebody
when because there's a lot of people I
still have a lot of friends that are
very liberal I still consider myself
fairly liberal on a lot of issues but I
have a lot of friends who just don't
know that a lot of this stuff is going
and it took an article about the black
face of white supremacy to actually wake
somebody up to the absolute
Ridiculousness and Brett that was a
headline it was a headline headline was
Larry Elder is the black face the white
supremacy sub headline you've been
warned yes did you find it and by the
way the woman that wrote her initials
are Erica D Smith oops and I invited her
on my radio show when the race was over
because I had two months left in my
contract and she wouldn't come on
well she can't platform white
supremacist right do you have this Frame
down your wall no but I will yeah you
should I do so I worked very hard for
that title yeah I actually see what the
is so so when we're talking about
like the pow like I talk a lot about the
power of the media and the most powerful
thing they can do is not talk about
something oh yeah uh that's what I'm
talking when you're we're talking Thomas
Soul we're talking about the fact that
you're saying that almost all these
black Americans don't know that Thomas
still exists that's because he's not
revered he's not actually put in to the
public Spotlight by anyone that they
would actually watch media from and all
they would have to do is highlight him
highlight his work but they don't
because he doesn't co-sign The Narrative
this is a story I don't believe I've
ever mentioned publicly you remind me of
it
um I had a book New York Times
bestseller book called The 10 things you
can't say in America first chapter was
blacks are more racist than white second
chapter is white condescension is as bad
as black racism and another chapter
about the war on drugs and about the war
on guns at first when it was Chris Rock
was a Chris Rock bit well because he
said but it's because they hate black
people too
I have a friend who Jesse Jackson does
not know is my friend and he my friend
used to work for operation rainbow push
in Chicago and he said Jesse Jackson's
office had a bunch of books bookcase
behind his desk but the books on his
table are the ones he was really reading
and there was a copy of my book on the
on his table and I
hit Jesse Jackson often in my book he
told me there was a conference call with
a bunch of so-called black leaders and
they said what are we going to do about
this mofo named Larry Elder and he said
they all agreed the star the smartest
strategy was to Simply ignore me exactly
and that's what they've done and I told
you all these years I've tried to get
these guys to come on they won't come on
they simply have ignored me they won't
even mention my name yep and they made a
group decision
group chat because it's just so creepy
um firstly the just to touch on the fact
that Thomas Saul wasn't mentioned it's
it's not just like Thomas Sowell is some
intellectual who happened to be black
like he is one of the best political
thinkers today he's brilliant anyone
who's read his work and he speaks so
clearly too he's not all over the place
he doesn't have trouble finding his
thoughts he just puts everything out
there in a perfectly like concise and
reasonable way and in everything he's
written that I've read has been
fantastic but of course he's ignored
because he's coming to conclusions which
are very clearly true on the number
things I don't agree with him on
everything but even when I disagree with
him he makes a remarkable case it's
thoughtful yeah Maxine Waters uh Gloria
Allred used to be on my same radio
station and Gloria and I are friends
even though I disagree with everything
she says and vice versa but we're
friends but she would always have Maxine
Waters on and one time I said Gloria
the next time you have Maxine Waters on
would you ask her why she won't come on
Larry older show she said sure I'll ask
her yeah so uh Gloria's talking to her
and then says uh Maxwell my friend Larry
Hill and my colleague here at KBC radios
wants to know why you won't come on this
radio show is there some reason why she
well you know Gloria uh uh Larry Elder
he's he's an Entertainer and and I don't
go on shows of Entertainer you got to
entertain the glory you are a serious
journalist and Larry it was Entertainer
so I'm not going on this show Gloria or
it is a serious journalist okay okay
fair enough it's all good proving you
really can't claim a couple weeks ago
Sheamus claimed it's fighting that's
right I decided I'm a journalists he was
journals and my favorite thing I
identify as a journalist yeah it's not
just that identified here's what I
realized watching media watching so many
journalists today what the vast majority
of people who call themselves
journalists do is they just read
articles and give you your opinion on
them which I do almost every day even
when we don't ask so I am a journalist
at least you're honest about it yeah
exactly
you don't report to be objective yeah a
journalist purports to be objective
they're not yeah and I think that's
that's so wrong I mean I mean I have an
objective you have an objective like a
lot of journals today which is actually
not what they're supposed to be doing
they're supposed to be giving you the
facts and as we've said a couple times
tonight you know the the the need for
accurate information and the the need
for critical thinking is so important
how can you be an active and healthy
citizen without those things but I will
say my favorite part about this was uh
Sheamus declared himself a journalist
here live on air that's right
heterosexual journalist yeah that's
right wow I know there's there aren't
many there are a lot uh and then put it
in his Twitter bio and then later told
me he did an interview in which the
person then was like reading his Twitter
and being like I think no I think she
was in on the joke yeah yeah yeah yeah
but she was like joining us tonight is
journalists and cartoonist okay so I'm
officially a journalist yeah she was she
was in on it but
outside of this I just think that is so
funny because really like what what
makes you a journalist I thought it was
being accurate and trying to be fair in
your reporting but perhaps I am wrong
it's yeah exactly actually it's one of
these words that has no meaning anymore
that's right that's uh we're journalists
dude we're both journalists at this
point it's interesting how one becomes a
journalist uh George Stephanopoulos used
to work for Bill Clinton he was his
communications director yeah yeah and
ABC News hires him and they say he's not
going to do any any political stuff and
then he started doing political stuff
and now he's evolved he's now their
Chief news anchor how did that happen
how does somebody who's a it was a
partisan for Bill Clinton wanted uh you
know big Health Care big taxes all the
stuff that they that the left wants now
all of a sudden he's evolved to be a
chief news anchor of ABC News well there
was so there was a really great quote
you know chomsky's not my favorite in
the world but he had this really great
moment on television decades ago
where he was talking to a reporter they
were interviewing him about his book and
they said to him he was basically
explaining that media Outlets will only
forward certain people who have a
specific set of values that line up with
the networks and the journalist becomes
a little bit indignant and they said are
you accusing me of not being sincere in
my values and Chomsky says no I believe
you are sincere what I'm telling you is
you wouldn't have this job if you
weren't you wouldn't have this job if
you didn't have those values right if
you tow the right line you're way more
likely to rise to the top this is what
we were saying earlier I mean if if
you're a right-wing person who works at
a left wing Outlet you're going to keep
your head down and I got to be honest
with people you might want to say I can
be conservative at one of these
organizations and keep my head down you
either live what you believe or you
believe what you live at some point
you're going to be in simulated right
you are who you they say you're you are
a combination of The Five People You
spend the most time with got to be
careful got to be out about your values
there's um there really aren't that many
wise things that John Lennon said but
there is one wise thing he did say he
said always tell the truth you won't
always make friends but you will make
the right ones I think that's completely
spot on this is what conservatives have
to be more open uh doing so you didn't
go you agree with imagine there's no
property I know imagine imagine no
believe it or not when a rich guy said
imagine there's no property it wasn't so
much that that song is replacing Old
Lang Syne as the New Year's Eve Anthem I
think yeah if you listen to it it's the
first thing they play after the Times
Square uh ball drop but he didn't used
to be like that they used to play before
whatever now instead of playing Auld
Lang Syne they play Imagine that's
creepy because John Hinckley to shoot
Ronald Reagan was that it imagine yeah
now it's because Gal Gadot did that
video where she sang it on Air Jordan
I'm sorry Mark David Champion right yeah
that's the one possibly yeah linen he
thought Lynn was a hypocrite because if
his wealth but had a song called imagine
there's no there's no
the thing is yeah John Lennon could have
easily imagined no possessions if he
gave his away but none of these
socialists do it's remarkable that was
the per I mean that's a perfect example
of great Hollywood propaganda right to
the average person it's just a person
that likes it it's just a song but if
you look deeper into the meaning you
understand that these motives these
objectives especially in Hollywood and
music and entertainment go long past
what we're experiencing now this is not
a new thing these values have been part
of these industries for decades upon
decades and this is how we ring in the
New Year in America like everyone should
freak out about this I forget to make
this George Harrison have a song called
tax man where you attack taxes I think
so pretty sure yes I think he did yeah
yeah I do remember that yeah well uh
we've got we've got another story here
queued up uh the doj is going to sue
Texas over Governor Abbott's floating
wall and razor wire along the Rio Grande
the justice department notified Texas
that it plans to file a lawsuit over the
latest tactic in operation Lone Star
Governor Greg Abbott's controversial
border security initiative a legal
challenge welcomed by Abbott tpr
confirmed on Friday that the justice
department sent a letter to Abbott's
office outlining that Abbott's floating
border barrier in the Rio Grande
violates federal law raises humanitarian
concerns and is a threat to Public
Safety and the environment okay so they
don't mention the fentanyl coming in
from yeah exactly they don't mention the
tens of thousands of children left
unaccounted for uh at the border who
yeah I mean when you want to talk about
a press release
can't get everything in Sheamus well and
I'd like to ask you this because you do
know the law not to put you on the spot
if you don't know the specifics of this
that's fine but I'm curious if you think
there's really a case here I don't one
of the limited duties of government is
to deal with immigration federal
government is not doing that if anybody
should be suing anybody Texas ought to
be suing doj amen yeah amen uh that's
why we just have to ship more busloads
up to these blue States and then maybe
they'll see I heard with the with the
mayor of New York just now said we've
had too many no that's right we're no
longer a sanctuary and then I said
imagine I said imagine no borders yeah I
said imagine no countries why don't you
let them in no religion too this is so
if you this is one of my one of my
favorite facts of American politics that
has become far more clear over the past
uh few years but when you place
left-wing people in the circumstances
that conservatives have been in for
decades they magically have this
Epiphany and begin to develop
conservative perspectives part of what
was so strategically brilliant about
these Governors and border states
shipping yeah shipping uh these these
migrants off to
blue States is they forced them to make
our arguments there's too many people we
can't support everyone who wants to
enter this country we don't have the
resources to take care of them okay if
you in New York City don't have the
resources to take care of these people
what about a poor Border Town in Texas
are you on your mind yeah you know there
was a study done by the Civil Rights
Commission some years ago and the group
most hurt by illegal aliens uh are black
and brown people living in the inner
city those with high school or List
education because virtually all of the
illegal aliens have very little
education there are about a million
fewer blacks who are working because of
the presence of illegal alien labor and
the presence of illegal alien labor puts
downward pressure to the tune of almost
two thousand dollars per year on the
salaries of people living in the inner
city yeah so once again the people who
are most likely to vote Democrat the
ones that left claims that they care
about black and brown people are the
ones most hurt yeah exactly it's crazy
to me that uh Texas or the doj is upset
because Greg Abbott says hey we're gonna
put up a barrier here because you're not
supposed to enter illegally and by the
way swimming across the Rio Grande is
incredibly dangerous so we should not be
incentivizing it as a way for people to
enter this country illegally anyways but
that doesn't matter right it's a
humanitarian crisis that uh that Greg
Abbott is standing in the way of floods
of illegal immigrations which apparently
Democrat parties benefit from and and I
think you're totally right to bring up
the fact that they uh
continuously fail to advertise the cost
and who is truly impacted by this I have
said over and over again that not only
are illegal immigrants uh themselves
especially people who are trafficked
across the border abuse and hurt in the
process but also every Community every
person affected by this pays a price
that when we say but it's just mean you
can't put a wall there you can't put
floating buoys in the water and
Democrats Democrats used to agree with
you I put on my uh my website uh a
montage I did some years ago of Bill
Clinton uh uh Barack Obama
um Dianne Feinstein a Chuck Schumer all
talking about the Damage Done by
unfairly illegal immigration uh Harry
Reid even used the the word illegal
alien and it was a book they all used to
say this and then they did a 180 when
they realized that the votes were were
among uh Hispanics and they figured that
at some point by letting a bunch of
illegal aliens in to be enough pressure
to put on to make them uh residents and
then citizens and then they would vote
vote Democrat if legal aliens turned
residents turned voters would vote
Republican we would not be having this
conversation well and not only that but
when they go to places that tend to vote
blue they artificially inflate
representation there the pollsters say
there are more people there so that they
have to you know increase their seats
but I also want to mention this horrible
horrible term you used illegal alien
don't you know that the preferred term
is friend we haven't made yet
but what Jerry you just said is true
because uh they point that out about
Cuban immigrants and people who come
over from Cuba that who they know have a
tendency not to vote in the same way
because they came from a socialist
country and so they don't play to that
demographic the same way they do those
at the Texas border wasn't there I I
might be misremembering but there was
this wet foot dry foot policy that
actually made it more difficult for
people who entered the nation uh on
wraps basically uh you know people who
came from Cuba to enter that's kind of
interesting yeah yeah there's a complete
bicep and what what I find uh like which
is totally disturbing as I mean first
off we have to acknowledge that Greg
Abbott responds with Texas has the
sovereignty to enforce border security
yeah and I have to you know you can
criticize Greg app for a lot of things
but I I really like that he has made
this a priority for his administration I
like that he is willing to make bold
choices
um again with the bus saying everyone
can accuse him of theatrics I think it's
good I think everyone should be aware of
what's going on uh and you know one of
the strangest things happened to me
since I began working conserved media is
I think Instagram figured it out even
though my Instagram is very you know
just personal and not political at all
uh it started sending me videos that
some of the Border Chiefs take and post
on their social media platforms and the
just obvious traffic that goes through
that area the obvious destruction that
comes through is uh something that I
wish more people talked about I didn't
seek that out Instagram has identified
me as a conservative they have figured
it out but it is interesting to to me
that you won't see that that reality
portrait I mean the obvious case of this
is uh with the the group of Haitian
migrants who are under the bridge and
trying to cross and um and Alexander
Majorca reprimanded the border patrol
officers who are on Horseback saying
they whipped them they did this around
it and they didn't they didn't they got
approved for testified against it and
mayorkers is still in office letting our
border policy continue and also not
standing by the agents who are doing
their best given the limited resources
that they have considering the federal
government consistently undermines
states that are trying to be proactive
like Texas and the difference between
Democrats that I assembled in that
Montage were complaining about legal
immigration 20 years ago and now the
average illegal immigrant coming from
the southern border was a Mexican on
foot coming across the border now 100 of
them pretty much have are paying cartels
yeah well and not not only that not only
that the basketball has been taken over
by the cartel the majority of people who
are being trafficked across the border
are not Mexican uh I was having a
conversation with Jenny Tara about this
who's a reporter and journalist an
actual one who who's gone down to the
Border several times what she told me is
that this is her she said she has not
spoken to a single Mexican the entire
time she's been down there now I
understand that that's anecdotal that's
the experience of one journalist but
statistically the majority of them are
not from Mexico no I was going to point
out our own show I'm going to cite
ourselves citing the Los Angeles Times
uh when the fourth bus of migrants
arrived in La this week from Texas the
majority were from Venezuela this is not
fair to anyone which is weird because
socialism is great I thought we loved
socialism I kid no one can explain it
well they're here to evangelize about
social they listen to the Imagine song
over there they heard it yeah yeah no I
mean I just think that immigration is
one of these issues that I'm so glad
that more people are talking about
because again it's the the fact that the
doj looks at Texas putting up a floating
buoy while the kind that you would see
like if you were swimming at a lake and
they're saying don't go too far uh
they're super racist but they are trying
to deter people from illegally entering
the country which by the way they are
risking their lives they're being put
into horrible situation while doing the
humanitarian crisis is Texas trying to
stop this and not the idea that anyone
is willing to take children and do this
take this journey is is crazy when Biden
got elected ABC's Martha raddatz
interviewed this guy who had just come
across the border and she said to him
would you have tried this if president
Trump had gotten reelected he said no of
course not
I'm shocked yeah she said really she
said
shocked
I'm going to try this are you kidding
yeah of course not one of the two people
respond to incentives people when the
laws are being enforced people are less
likely to break them is now wild one of
the statistics that uh Republicans quote
a lot especially when uh Andy Briggs uh
Biggs entered the motion to uh uh
impeach majorcus a little bit earlier
this year one of the statistics comes up
is the number of people who are on the
FBI's most wanted list who are
apprehended at the border and they're
saying there are more people apprehended
at the border on the fa most wanted list
under Biden and that sounds a little
weird like they're no better job of
catching them no it's because under
Trump they didn't come near the border
that's right there's like there's way
more this is way more they do things
like this those are the ones they caught
exactly they also do things where
they'll say like oh Barack Obama
actually stopped more people from
crossing the border than Bush did that's
not true they just redefined what it
meant to stop somebody at the border
under the Obama Administration sure and
they had uh what was it title 42 where
there were all sorts of issues uh with
related to kova that we ended up
terminating because the Biden
Administration took away and then had to
put it back I mean I think the The
Immigrant duration issue is just
profound it really affects our country I
was wondering if you want to talk a
little bit more about your stance yeah I
was a potential president uh are you are
you looking to restrict any legal
immigration I would put back the Trump
policies that gave us the most secure
border we've ever had uh the stay in
Mexico policy I would stop catching
release I would apprehend and uh and put
in confinement the people who are
crossing the border illegally because
that's the only way you can Deport them
once you put them in the interior
they're going to stay forever yeah um
but yeah we we need temporary workers if
they're truly temporary uh and there are
some high skilled uh workers that we
that we need but we should determine the
number the amount and how long they stay
so can I ask you something just related
not necessarily to Illegal immigration
but your own policies what what would be
your administration's priority what's
the first thing that you would do if you
were elected first thing I would do uh
is to stop this war on oil and gas allow
drilling on federal properties and I
would uh finish the wall uh and uh again
reverse the anti Trump policies that
Biden has implemented those are the
first couple things I would do yeah you
don't want to keep the shipping
containers that they have in Arizona
actually they made Doug Ducey take them
down right these gaps in the walls
how did The Catch and Release policies
affect the migrants that were brought in
and then bus to other other states
busted blue States nothing I mean once
once you're here there's no way to get
you out unless you're willing to go
door-to-door and drag people out and of
course uh the media images will be such
that the NAACP I mean you mean they
might once once they are here
they have a court date and it's supposed
to show up if you don't nothing happens
it's wild well and that's the thing I I
tend to agree with you people will say
we can't do deportations they're so
horrible I agree it's an ugly thing
that's why we need a very strong border
so that we can minimize the number of
deportations necessary would you agree
do you agree with ending birth rate
citizenship because it incentivizes I
don't believe that the 14th Amendment
ever really conferred Birthright
citizenship it's way the Supreme Court
has interpreted it or the way we think
the Supreme Court has interpreted it but
the drafter that wanted to make sure
that a Black's newly freed blacks were
treated equally it was not designed to
say if you come here illegally drop a
kid that kid is an American citizen it
was not designed for that at all yeah I
think these are all interesting reforms
I wonder if you would uh want to expand
a little more on potentially capping
legal immigration you're mentioning that
skilled workers but maybe right I don't
have a number in mind but the point is
there are workers who have skills that
we don't have uh science technology
engineering math kinds of people and I
have no problem with having a certain
number of H-1B visas provided they're
they're temporary and there's certain
Fields agriculture where there's work
that people will do at prices that we're
unwilling to pay and that's seasonal we
should be able to do that and and make
sure that people go back yeah that's
interesting I I find H1B Visa is such an
such an interesting area because you
know I've heard I've talked to a lot of
young Democrats actually who talk about
brain drain in the states and I feel
like we have a responsibility to
acknowledge that when we incentivize you
know another country's best and
brightest away and don't encourage them
to return we are actually doing that
country a disservice well our job is to
do America a service not not to worry
about other other countries I'm an
America first guy but but we would not
need to import these kinds of people if
we were doing better job K-12 yeah yeah
I mean and that's that's absolutely
correct people will talk often about the
fact that we're effectively uh importing
in underclass we're bringing people in
who have no skills to have them do jobs
that Americans aren't unwilling to do
but would do if they they paid a more
decent wage and
what people don't want to acknowledge is
that it's also the case that when you're
importing people with h-1bs I think
sometimes that can be good but what we
should want is for our country to
produce citizens who are capable of
doing those jobs right and we shouldn't
use H1B Visa as a means to get rid of
people who are doing the jobs just to
pay the workers coming in less money
yeah yeah absolutely exploitation so um
where where are your stances on some of
the other uh hot button issues right now
how would you how do you feel I I think
I can probably make some guesses I know
you're more conservative but when it
comes to like the lgbtq lobby or your
stance on abortion or federal abortion
ban where would you put yourself well on
abortion I am pro-life but it's an issue
that should be determined by the states
the way it was until 1973 when the
Supreme Court took up Roe v Wade every
state will determine its own own path I
think our side falls down we don't put
the other side on the spot and ask them
at what point do you believe a pregnancy
has gone so far that determinated would
become a murder I try to get Gavin
Newsom to answer that question nobody
would answer it I was called an
extremist
and Bernie Sanders however in one of the
debates did say it's up to a woman to
choose really it's Insanity a moment
before birth so that guy who behind bars
in Philadelphia Dr Kermit Gosnell should
be free because remember that guy that
was prosecuted for performing late-term
abortions I guess he's been persecuted
he's a political prisoner he should be
let go the the left is never put the
task on giving us a definition at what
point do they feel pregnancy has gone so
far yeah I also think I also think
though um
shame is that the pro-life people have
not only talked the talk they've walked
the walk there are thousands of
pregnancy centers all over the country
with resources for Education uh and for
job training and there are probably 35
couples for every one baby uh willing to
adopt so the resources are there women
have other choices and we should make it
clear to them that they do have another
Choice other than they have to have an
abortion you're absolutely correct that
uh there are more couples on the waiting
list to adopt and there are unplanned
pregnancies in the US each year when you
look at the statistics of women who have
abortion they often say it's because
they didn't think there was any other
option anyone willing to help them again
that's not an excuse but it just goes to
show that if we have these resources for
them if we let them know that life was
an option then they'd be willing to
choose it I will disagree on one thing I
do believe in a federal abortion ban I
think we have to protect life in all
cases in all states I think that to me
it's hypocritical for me to years for
years say that Rollie Wade never should
have been taken up that the Supreme
Court never should have found invalid
every single abortion law of all the
other other states to make this a
federal issue and then it's say on the
other hand Roe v Wade is overturned now
let's have a federal Bill Ronald Reagan
was at least principally consistent when
he said that he was going to push for an
amendment to ban abortion yeah that
would be something that would would be
consistent legally he didn't do it but
he said he would do that yeah that's
something I would like I so my position
is not that Roe v Wade was necessarily
bad because it overturned every State's
laws I do think that is a negative about
it but primarily because it allowed for
unborn children to be killed in the
United States
well they already were yes
California in fact that's true the
majority of women lived uh there was
pretty much abortion on demand even
before we Roe v Wade yeah no that that's
correct that's correct and I would still
see that as an evil but I I love that
you brought up the Pregnancy Center so
if I can just interject here uh the
couple weeks ago I read an article about
how Yelp in particular this is in the
wake of Roe was specifically flagging
Pregnancy Center so centers that offer
you know like you're mentioning
Healthcare Services they don't offer
abortion they might talk to you about
adoption as an option they might talk to
you about job training other kinds of
support uh Yelp was in particular uh
trying to warn people that this is not
what you're looking for and they're
trying to make sure that they could
distinguish between them and I find that
to be somewhat sad right I I feel as
though we should uh always encourage
women to know that there are other
options I I personally feel like there's
a lot a lot to be said for foster care
reform in this country but like you're
saying it's not that there are spaces in
homes where people are willing to foster
it's that there are couples willing to
adopt absolutely changes that could be
made to the adoption process
well the option is hard because foster
care ultimately the game the the aim of
foster care is to reunite children with
their parents right and I think that's
honorable and I think that's good I
think we also can agree that there are
some people who just through the
circumstances of their lives the the
positions they're in are not capable of
raising their children and that those
children deserve to be with loving
stable parents who can give them as much
as possible so it's a really tricky
conversation because I would never this
is a conversation that I had with a lot
of Libertarians as I was uh as combing
through my philosophy because you know I
don't want the state to tell me how to
parent on the other hand I think we can
all look at some circumstances and say
you should not have your children I mean
there are enough uh terrible cases of uh
of of of fatal abuse of children that I
don't need to give you an example right
like we know this happens uh and how we
navigate that as a culture in society
for me it's small scale you need to have
communities that are responsible for
what's going on there but that also
means you have to know your neighbors
and you have to know your values
adoption you know I don't know if you
want to jump in here but adoption
doesn't necessarily it's not necessarily
an easy path I just think it's something
that more people should consider and I
think especially for women who are in a
position if they're not ready to raise a
child
um that you know number one really is
that are are you not wanting to but you
are capable of it and also uh what are
your options because there is probably
someone who would be willing to do and
there are a lot of couples that simply
cannot conceive a lot of them yeah I was
campaigning in Iowa recently and there
was a elderly couple and I started
talking to them and asking what they
would what they did and I asked them
they had they had children and uh she
said no he said no and I said if you
don't mind my asking I may ask you why
and she said
he couldn't get me pregnant he said he's
sitting there he goes put it all on him
yeah yeah and I said did you guys
consider adoption and they said we
considered it we decided against it but
looking back at it we wish we had yeah
um it's such a sad thing too because now
you have so many people doing in vitro
which requires for you to create new
life that ends up being destroyed in the
process when there are so many children
who need a home I mean there's so many
children out there who could have a
family who could have a loving childhood
if they were adopted and you can make
the argument that there are some people
who might adopt that child and their
life might be less than ideal sure but
they're alive they haven't been killed
we're also moving towards designer
pregnancies with surrogacy and things
like that I was going to Russia Sophia
so I have an article up on Tim cast
right now because I just couldn't not
write it because Sofia Vergara the
Modern Family actress announced that
she's getting divorced and I can't see
her without thinking about uh the
article her ex Nick slobe wrote about
his battle to gain essentially custody
although embryos are treated like
property uh of the Frozen embryos that
they had created to together that she
said you know I don't want children out
there with my DNA that I'm not raising I
don't want you to raise them and I don't
want to be reclassified as an egg donor
and so those frozen embryos are still on
ice and they exist they are you know
it's it's a really I I summarized in the
article you should all check it out on
timcast.com because it's great uh no but
it I mean part of it is the argument
around when does Life Begin and also if
you made an agreement so one of the
things I found interesting maybe you can
comment on this uh is they had to sign a
contract saying you know they would
bring they were always going to use a
surrogate and they were going to
mutually consent to to uh to have these
children born into the world but there
wasn't a contingency as apparently is
required by California state law I'm not
a legal expert I can't speak to this uh
for them they were supposed to make a
plan for what happens if they split up
and they did not so he wanted was the
contract executed in California I
believe so that's an invalid contract
now they've ruled a California judge
ruled in her favor they said that he was
aware of this agreement that they agreed
to mutually bring the children into the
world so therefore the fact they broke
up is irrelevant this is what we call a
man-made beyond our comprehension
this stuff is just it's insane you're
seeing the celebrities now it's not even
because of inability to get pregnant
it's that they don't want to damage
their body and they want to the women
don't want the stretch marks they don't
want to go through the process of birth
and then there's stories of celebrities
who are then saying after the fact
shockingly I had a hard time connecting
with my child after they were born
because they didn't actually go through
the process of giving birth to the baby
well it's it's not just that I mean
there are people who adopt children and
and I know people who've adopted
children and what I will say is I can't
tell you the statistics on how often
they bond but I would argue it probably
happens often I would imagine they bond
pretty well because when you adopt a
child that's a choice that is made
selflessly right whereas there there is
and look I know there are a lot of
people I've spoken to and known who have
done in vitro and done surrogacies and I
want everyone who hears me saying this
who's done that to understand I'm not
saying there's anything wrong with your
child I'm glad your child is in the
world if somebody is the victim of abuse
and they become pregnant I think the
abuse was wrong but I'm glad that that
child exists right so I don't hate you I
don't hate your child but I really think
it's wrong and I I think ultimately it
is a selfish decision that results in
human life being destroyed and also it
in some sense makes it less it makes it
more difficult for children who you
could have adopted who could have had a
home who could have had a loving family
to end up seeing that home because one
was made in a Petri dish instead yeah
well and I'll say from the research I've
done with adoption and the interviews
I've I've listened to with people who
adopt part of it is they they know
they're adopting they know this child
comes from different circumstances maybe
the child is you know adopted to them
right from the hospital maybe this child
has you know been in in the world for a
little while and they intentionally
cultivate relationships and they you
know some people talk about like uh
cocooning they'll specific quickly spend
a lot of time as a nuclear family
letting this child adjust to it before
they venture out into the world and you
know I can't say for sure but maybe with
surrogacy some people expect because it
is your your tissue that you'll have
that experience and I think uh pregnancy
is a very unique experience and I think
also that that's one of the beautiful
things about adoption that people
intentionally go into knowing that they
are going to maybe have to put a little
more work in but the the bonding and
love can be just as real yeah
I'm saying about
um the idea that there are women that
make a career now out of cert you know
being surrogates right like there's when
you actually paid for it yeah like
what's like uh was it Kim Kardashian or
something underpaid her her surrogate or
something like that like and you just
think about that and this is a woman
said she's done it multiple times and
you're just like that's that's what she
uses with the going rate I don't I don't
even know what it was but the fact is
there's a going rate at all I've seen it
no I've seen some of the numbers it's
like in its look there is no amount of
money except there's no amount of money
that makes that worth it but I've seen
some some statistics that say like 30
000 foreign
they'll give you extra money for food uh
if you're Kim Kardashians you're
probably also paying for her silence
that sounds a little odd but like you're
paying her not to go to the media and be
like I'm Kim Kardashian surrogate since
make him get pregnant I guess it's a job
that men can do too it's so I mean the
whole Situation's so sad this is what we
forget this is part of why a country
like this a free Nation a nation with a
market system can only function with a
virtuous population there are some
things you cannot sell there are some
things you should not be able to sell
this is one of those things imagine the
trauma that a person goes through giving
birth for a child just to give it away
for money right we're not talking about
I have this child and I and and I know I
loved them I didn't want to abort them I
did the right thing by them but I
couldn't take care of them so I gave
them to a family who could we're just
we're talking I got pregnant to make
this money and now what do you think is
going to happen you think a woman who's
pregnant informing that bond with that
child is going to go well they're paying
me so now I'm not going to form this
spiritual and physical and neurochemical
bond with the child in many instances in
which the surrogate mother has changed
her mind yeah and the courts have
decided excited with the surrogate
mother yep that's good yeah yeah that is
good I'm glad to hear that I'm glad
there's a legal precedent for that thing
for siding with the mother it's such a
sad thing it's such a sad thing overall
um but we are actually going to head
over to Super chats now where we're
going to let the fans uh ask us some
super chats yes so people who who
chatted yeah give us a couple dollars
yeah here we are
so we have uh from I'm not your buddy
guy says it does bother me that many
leaders in the west especially in the US
are acting is if they know they can
never be removed from Power again that's
an interesting point what do you guys
think about term limits
um
I'm saying we need term limits we've had
term limits in California for a number
of years States gotten bigger and bigger
what happens is the special interests
know what's going on the politicians are
trying to figure out where the bathroom
is next thing you know they're termed
out but I do believe in term limits for
voters just kidding after you voted
Democrat two or three times you lose
your right to vote I propose that and
nobody uh picked it up
one thing I'll say too this is part of
my co-sponsored that bill this is why
this is kind of the reason why I don't
like term limits because politicians who
are going to lie to you and steal from
you or a dime a dozen we're going to get
plenty of those and term limits aren't
really going to get rid of those people
but the the once in a generation type
leaders who actually come around and
want to do the right thing they then
only get a few years to lead when
historically you know they could be
elected and re-elected and re-elected
and re-elected because they did such a
good job it's all about choice I should
have the choice to choose somebody over
and over and over again if I want to
that said I think there is something to
be said especially when looking at our
current political landscape about there
being
um you know cognitive tests and much
harsher adherence to standards that
would ensure that those in power you're
not referring to Joseph Robinette no
we're referring to Diane Pines the thing
is there's like a few
couple years I could have been referring
to but now yes Joe Biden this is
something I remember hearing my entire
childhood and you know when I was
learning about politics in school when I
was learning about the history of the
80s
they would mock the Republicans for
having a president Ronald Reagan who
they claim ended up becoming demented or
senile towards the end of his presidency
that may or may not be true I can't tell
you the history there I can't tell you
whether what I was being told in school
about that is accurate but what I can
tell you is this is after he was already
elected Joe Biden was clearly in steep
cognitive decline during the primaries
and they chose him to be their candidate
and by the way
Reagan's age was an issue when he ran he
was 69 years old when he got elected I
am older than that Trump is older than
that Biden is older than that
if he were to be elected if he were to
serve out his old second term he'd be 87
when he left oh my God
the average voter who is not heavily
politically informed doesn't know that
this stuff is going on they don't see
the montages they know Joe Biden is old
yeah but they're not seeing the videos
of him
Tony Bennett just died at 94. come on he
could have been president yeah
but I don't think United States
Joe Biden isn't healthy for his age you
know he's not because he can't sing
yeah you want Tony Bennett singing and
dancing until he until the end of his
life no like where is Dubai's family be
like hey man you've had a long career
too much money it seems like it's time
to step back well this is the thing
that's crazy I think that it's possible
we don't know why God makes the decision
he made or makes his thoughts are not
our thoughts Joe Biden is an old man who
we know has done many horrible things
and promoted many horrible things this
could be God's way of giving him as many
second chances to repent is possible
let's hope he takes one of them at some
point let me give you my prediction
people are now speculating that uh Joe
Biden won't be able to to make it won't
be able to fog up a mirror uh and Kamala
Harris is even less popular
the nominee if Joe Biden cannot fog up a
mirror will be Kamala Harris and here's
why when
Bernie Sanders won the Nevada caucuses
uh in 2020 and for a moment for a brief
Shining Moment he became the party's
front-runner a Democrat socialist they
panicked James Clyburn on the eve of the
South Carolina primary uh endorsed Joe
Biden with a promise that his first
supreme court nominee would be a black
female
Joe Biden hired a black female to be his
running mate Gavin Newsom when it
appeared that Dianne Feinstein might not
serve out her last term promised to
appoint a black female
to kick aside the first black female
who's on base to become the first black
female president by a white person like
mayor Pete or Gavin Newsom black voters
will be livid and the first primary is
where South Carolina and 60 of the
voters are black majority of those are
black female Nepal show black females
love love love Kamala Harris and they
resent the mocking of her so-called
cackle they think it's sexist and racist
and they believe that Joe Biden's given
her thankless tasks like finding the
root causes of illegal immigration so if
you if you do that and shove her aside
for somebody else who's white black
voters won't vote Republican they just
won't vote thereby and guaranteeing
whoever the nominee is on the Republican
side he or she will win they can't do
that so they are stuck with Biden Harris
that is so interesting I've never heard
that analysis before
thank you very much and if I'm wrong
this didn't happen
what would you say I'm curious do you
know what the polling data is on black
man and black men in Kamala Harris
I don't I'm sure she's not as popular
among black men as she is among black
females by the way black men 20 of them
voted for uh Republicans in 2020. well
that's the thing the the uh share of
black men voting Republican has
increased Donald Trump got eight percent
of the black vote in 2016 he got 12 and
20 20 50 increase we got 20 of the black
male vote but I thought Joe Biden said
if you don't Joe Biden you're not black
well Joe Biden was raised in the Black
by the way he said that on Charlemagne
the God show yes and Charlemagne tha God
wasn't even insulted
um yeah if you look at the tape Biden's
wait wait wait wait wait if you don't
know if you want to vote for me or vote
for Trump you're really black and
Charlemagne wasn't even insulted here he
is this white dude who's lied for
decades about his civil rights record
claiming that he segregated desegregated
movie theaters and restaurants in
Delaware no evidence he ever did it he
was raised in the black church people in
the black church said they never saw him
he lied and lied and lied said he tried
to visit Nelson Mandela during apartheid
South Africa no evidence of it he's lied
for decades about his civil rights
record and tells you Charlemagne the God
a black man who's down with the brother
others you ain't really black if you
don't want to vote for me and he wasn't
even insulted well I am the black face
of white supremacy not only has Biden
lied about his civil rights record but
he openly publicly stated very early on
in his career that he wasn't marching in
Selma he made all sorts of statements
early on distancing himself from the
civil rights movement and now today he
says the whole reason I got into
politics was the Civil Rights Movement I
was like what to oppose it like yeah he
said the reason the reason and the
reason he ran was because
Charlottesville that guy Donald Trump
you know he said uh there were good guys
and bad guys on the side of being
fascists and of course Donald Trump
never said anything like that he said
the opposite he said quote and I'm not
talking about the white Nationals and
Neo-Nazi because they should be
condemned totally in the vote that's
right even Jake Tapper two years after
the incident said you know I went back
look at the tape and Donald Trump was
talking about the debate on whether or
not there should be a Confederate
monument in the Public Square and then
two days after Jake Tapper said it Biden
is on CNN and says it again and nobody
said a word just blatantly lied uh
typical sleepy gel that one gamer said
I'm proud to say that Larry was my first
vote in LA county in the gubernatorial
recall just curious as to what Larry's
thoughts are on gun control
uh what do you think I'm a second
amendment guy interesting uh we're
talking about uh Donald Trump a moment
ago how many times have the Democrats
refer to him as a tyrant or a dictator
or a fascist
I ask you gentlemen and Lady what is the
purpose of the Second Amendment
uh to keep and bear arms to fight
tyranny hello so if you believe Donald
Trump is a tyrant why in the world would
you want further gun control
restrictions when after all the
amendment is designed to prevent
somebody like Donald Trump the Tyrant
from taking power you ought to be hoping
that more law-abiding people have more
guns it seems like the Tyrant would be
the one saying which means either
they're lying and being a demagogue when
they refer to him as a tyrant or they
have no clue what the second amendment's
really they don't know at the second
either word either way is bad they don't
know what the second amendment's for
they they don't actually believe that
that's uh they don't understand anything
about well-regulated militia uh and it's
open to their interpretation which is
just not the accurate interpretation of
that
um Raymond g Stanley Jr says Hannah
Claire is it me or was Lindell mad
sketchy today a lot of huff and puff dot
dot dot well done this week y'all not
even one YouTube strike
thank you guys so much I mean first off
what's he referring to yeah well this
morning I hosted our culture War show
which is a debate program and I had Matt
Brainerd on and he wanted to talk to
Mike Lindell about election security and
uh you know really it was about it was
supposed to be about early voter turnout
there was a lot of heated back and forth
and uh I will say it's not that I
thought Mike Lindell was sketchy it's
just that uh I think there was a lot of
uh I feel like I shouldn't review the
debate but I feel like there was a lot
of tension in the room you know they're
both people who feel really strongly and
passionately about what they do and
occasionally it felt like they were
going back and forth about well you're
questioning me well you're questioning
me
um but I'm ultimately so grateful to
have the opportunity to have people who
want to see
um you know their parties Victor uh have
Victory and they want to see change in
America so Mike Lindell really wants to
uh find ways to have more secure
elections to make sure that your vote
matters and uh Matt Brainerd is is of
course advocating for early voting
because he says you know these are the
tools we have at hand and we need to
push forward that and I think it's an
important conversation uh but Lively
very very Lively Serge and I uh I think
both had to get her ears checked
afterwards it's interesting that the uh
the Democrats have quote put democracy
on the ballot when they refer to people
like Donald Trump uh who believes that
the election was stolen as undermining
our Republic for the entirety of Trump's
term Hillary Clinton referred to him as
illegitimate to the election was stolen
that's right uh nobody called her an
election denier and Jay Johnson Obama's
DHS secretary testified under oath that
while the Russians tried they failed to
change a single vote tally in 2016.
there was a yougov poll two-thirds 66
percent of Democrats believe the
Russians quote change votales close
quote to elect Donald Trump that's right
yeah zero evidence voters so who's being
a little a greater percentage of those
guys believe that 2016 was stolen than
we feel 2020 was stolen but nobody calls
him elected deniers well when they
claimed the election was stolen we
investigated the candidate when
Republicans claimed the election was
stolen they investigated the Republicans
so that's all you need to know about
that Noah Sanders says when are these
Tim Cass beanies going to be available
for at least members give the people
what they want Potato Man firstly I
don't appreciate the slur against my
Irish ethnicity
that's a hate crime secondly what do you
mean this is just how we normally dress
what are they talking about I don't know
Tim I'm not really sure Tim do you know
by the way why why is it okay to call
the Notre Dame Fighting Irish
I think no one's even willing to come to
the defense of the idea that that
stereotype's not true they're like no
that's just how they are but I assume
you don't find that offensive no I don't
it's actually funny because I remember
being a little kid and seeing it and
finding it offensive and then I was like
Mom look at that and she laughed at it
she's like oh it's funny right and then
I was like okay I guess that's uh what
we do
I said Mom how dare you I said you're a
self-hating Irish I've not heard anybody
complain about it don't get me wrong I
just wonder no no no it's a good
question no I agree with you it's
because it's stupid later who cares it's
a little joke it's a little caricature
but like but the Washington Redskins
that's got to go but yeah that's
horrible dude well it's funny because
this guy there's a funny picture of um
uh a Native American dude wearing a
shirt that says like the Caucasians and
Liberals are like oh how would you feel
about that I was like every white person
I know thinks that's funny
that's a funny joke the Cleveland
Caucasian I've actually talked to a
friend of mine who's Native American and
one of the reasons they say that uh why
it's less offensive for the Fighting
Irish is because there were IR people of
Irish extraction that were on the board
of the school so it's not seen that way
whereas when these other organizations
were formed whether we're talking about
we're not talking about not the Redskins
but um if we're talking about the
Indians right like the idea is there
they were like they had the first uh
Native American players that's right it
was named after him to honor this guy
but now they're saying that there's
nobody in the front office yes and then
him and him and then two more right
after that right so they were doing
honor him they weren't doing it to even
talk about a tribe or anything too much
time what's the problem yeah but this
never comes up I feel like this is the
first I've ever heard me the reason is
what they're saying is that because
there's nobody in the front office that
actually has voting power for the team
that that makes defense representation
yes on the boards of uh on the board of
Notre Dame you know that you're going to
have somebody who's representing the
players who are on the team yes but that
representation is irrelevant Celtics is
okay too right
about this Celtics I know I have I have
a theory about this which is okay so
when you have a good friendship with
somebody you can make fun of them you
can poke fun at each other and it's fine
if you're in a healthy relationship with
someone you're your girlfriend or your
wife you can tease each other you can
make fun of each other but sometimes you
see that couple who joke about each
other and they're clearly being nasty
and trying to disguise it as banter and
it's extremely uncomfortable I think
where we are as a nation today with
racial politics is we are that second
couple where you make a joke and maybe
even in the moment the joke you're
making is just light-hearted but because
the relationship's gotten so sour people
are angered by it people think you're
making a dig whereas when the races are
actually getting along we're able to
make fun of each other it's actually a
sign of Health when different racial
groups can make fun of each other for
things that are unique to that group and
again if it's your friend group I think
that's one of the differences right when
we're talking about the internet these
are people you don't know in the real
world if it's your friend group that's
different unless your friends throw you
overboard let's take a little more
remember I made that joke where he was
talking to Senators I think was Josh
Hawley uh and he said I would have been
a house inward yeah and he got hammered
and Ice Cube goes on his show and says I
knew you were going to eff up at some
point he got hammered now Bill Moore
prized himself on his friendship with
blacks has a lot of black friends I'm
confident privately they shoot the
inward back and forth all the time so he
said it in a joking way I thought funny
and he got hammered and not a single one
of his black friends stood up and said
yo come on Bill's down with us we joke
like this all the time they threw him
under the bus yeah yeah I mean you're
right that's very possible especially
because if someone's gonna say that on
television to a black person the idea
that they haven't like tested that with
their own little market research behind
the scenes he said to a white person a
senator Joshua of Missouri yeah oh there
were no so there were no black people it
was even funnier he said he said well
you would have been I forget where how
it came up you had been a slave no I
would have been a house something like
and it was funny I thought it was funny
and what I'm saying is none of his black
friends stood up and said come on it was
funny A and B Bill Maher and I were good
friends he's down with the people we say
kind of stuff privately all the time it
was an innocent joke nobody backed him
up they all threw him under the bus so
they didn't want to get canceled by the
black community that's crazy we have one
from uh Bruce Maximus for Mr Elder would
allowing churches or similar to
established boarding schools to enact
cultural uh excuse me culture transplant
on through the school choice initiatives
be able to ameliorate some moral some
Modern moral degradation
do I believe that churches should set up
schools to to teach people stuff yes
[Laughter]
the church that I go to has all sorts of
schools camps and things like that I'm
encouraging churches to get involved I
mean it's crazy that we ever decided
that education should be the primary
responsibility and duty of the state
right this is what families should do
the majority of our nation's history was
not yeah it was done by communities
organizations in the community and
there's no and there's no evidence that
with the state took it over the equality
has gotten any better what was the
reason I mean did this have a lot to do
with
um cities like cities expanding had
everything to do with people wanting to
get paid more okay
um
oh sorry I wasn't sure if you I didn't
want to interrupt you
um I had a brilliant thought and you no
no go ahead no no no it's gone
the collective IQ of the whole audience
has now gone down Five Points
it's because
the racism
this is unbelievable racism
this is how I end my week yes this whole
week I'm working hard time
you really are the black face white
supremacy calling me the race home
without it
look here's the thing about the race
card I'm Irish which means we weren't
considered white until being white meant
you had to apologize for being white so
we like got in at the worst possible
moment unbelievably frustrating I'm also
Slavic which I've been told means that I
am a person of color you actually are
According to some yeah and we just had a
gay pride month we should have a take it
easy on the white man month I would
agree I think that should be everything
lighten up on white Iman yeah exactly as
president it's brutal it's brutal man
it's rough it's not a good year to be a
white male it hasn't been for a couple
years though a couple years yeah
sometime now you guys have had some
problems we have well like like I said
it's we've been talking about this it's
okay to bash white people it's okay to
bash man it's okay to bash straight
people it's okay to bash Christians not
only okay actually that's too light we
say it's okay it's not like you're
required to yeah you are actually
required to hate white people to hate
men to hate the family to hate
Christians well Sheamus they've held
power for too long that's right these
times
those white men just gotta is get out of
the way and let the rest of us have a
voice
um it's well it's one of these crazy
things every now and again you'll have
some awards ceremony that people cry
about giving a majority of their Awards
to white people and it ends up being
proportionate to the population so it's
like you know they gave 65 percent of
their Awards to white people it's like
well yeah that's because it's like 65 of
people in the country okay never mind no
no capital country a lot of white people
in this country I don't know if you
notice that yeah yeah a boatload of them
no I've noticed far too many you know it
really bothers me that's the other thing
too they can literally cheer up don't
worry they're a global minority so you
don't have to you don't have to stress
about it and that that can be cheered
for right when somebody says like yeah
statistically in the United States if
Trends continue white people are going
to be a minority like left-wing people
will celebrate that could you imagine
celebrating that about any other group
of people sickening it's really
sickening we had a Super Chat pulled up
here but then I guess you could say I
lost my train of thought here we go uh
Bruce Maximus for Mr Elder would you
then consolidate all taxes into one
figure that is remove corporate tax and
place it in the income tax as the
consumer pays it either way so better to
me make it apparent well you don't want
to know what I would do if I were in
charge I will tell you if I were in
charge I would limit taxes to what the
founding fathers intended which as I
said earlier the limited governments of
limited duties powers of government
government would be so small that its
obligations would be funded on duties
and tariffs which is what the founding
fathers intended and the Constitution
had to be amended for the for the income
tax if you look at the Constitution none
of this stuff Social Security Medicare
Medicaid none of that was envisioned by
the founding fathers and can I ask you
this if I could rule the world which I
could which I can't I put it back to
that do you think it would be possible
you mentioned that you wanted spending
to be at 10 of GDP do you think it would
be possible to have that much revenue
with those policies yes uh if you look
at some of the things that we meaning
the government operates whether it's
Amtrak whether it's the national parks
there are lots of things that could be
leased the Hoover Dam I could go on and
on and on about things government's
running that the private sector could
run and we could generate fees and
meet the small limited obligation that
the federal government is supposed to
have yes we can be done okay here's uh
is this one this is uh so from Dan
Sherman oh no I'm sorry well
yeah from Roma Nation do you think
there's a possibility that the reason
Biden was chosen by the quote deep State
unquote was to fix the issues that he
created with the Ukraine Scandal so it
doesn't expose other people in the
government doing the same thing
um I think Tim said something like that
last week but
here's the thing there our government's
been doing a lot of meddling in Ukraine
and there are a lot of political leaders
who have an incentive to cover that up
it's not like Joe Biden's the only
person who who would be able to do that
I don't know regarding Ukraine in
general uh Putin has already lost his
War when The Invasion started I watched
a lot of Television I've watched a lot
of these pundits including on Fox they
all thought the The Invasion would take
two three days maybe a couple of weeks
uh and then uh Ukraine would be
flattened the only issue was how far
Putin would go would he threaten the
NATO countries and invoke Article Five
this is now deep into the second year
Putin has lost at least 200 000 troops
that would be the equivalent of us
losing 400 000 troops 20 generals have
been killed either on the battlefield or
have disappeared there's been an
attempted coup uh he's his his hold on
power has never been more tenuous he's
looking for an off-ramp we ought to give
him one we have here from satosha
catergator keeping families together and
promoting the Catholic sense of
subsidiarity would solve a myriad of
socio-economic issues completely agreed
by the way uh
her and I don't clearly don't always
agree on everything because she just
said also I want to publicly apologize
for accusing shames of stealing anything
thank you thank you I appreciate that I
deserve to choose you stealing something
so I've been accused of stealing spoons
from Tim there's been a heinous smear
campaign
stories up about me it's really just not
acceptable uh and so I have been
maintaining my innocence you guys know
me you know I would you weren't stealing
you were just an undocumented Shopper I
wasn't even an undocumented Shopper you
guys know me you know I wouldn't do
something like that I would never do
something like that I still have yet to
see James use a spoon I just want to say
that there we go look at that she smells
his fingers I've seen him use forces in
your thighs I've never seen them so he
does use cut Cutlery yes he is civilized
enough yeah I've never you and there you
have it from the the one of the best
journalists if I do say so myself here
at timcast that I didn't do anything
that's what she just said in this room
at the very least no no I wouldn't go
that fast the only one the only one yes
thank you for admitting
no no I've been endorsed by a
presidential candidate you guys can't
stop me now that's right
secretary
that's because I'm speaking truth to
power no no I have a new job now you're
you're good enough to be asking to be a
press secretary I think you can do it so
if you want uh HC to be my press
secretary I need 40 000 individual
owners get be one dollar go to
larryolder.com make sure I get up there
on that debate stage she becomes my
president I now have steak in this game
guys
incentivized her you have by the way you
know one of the candidates is offering a
20 gift certificate for every one dollar
donation what is this the coveted
vaccine and another one is offering a
quote free concert if you donate one
dollar another one is giving uh giving
uh donors a commission to seek other
potential donors I'm not doing that
these seem like good deals I'm doing it
the old-fashioned way I'm asking people
for their support what's what's the
concert is it Taylor Swift it's a it's a
country western concert some guy I don't
know that's not my genre I would
consider if it's Taylor Swift I'll be
honest with you all right those tickets
are going straight I know it's not
Taylor Swift okay then I'm back to
running for president
um we have Chad cunego author who said
instead of term limits what about having
term penalties in other words for every
term you win you have to win by a higher
percentage at the next election and I
never heard that I
yeah I think it's a better idea than
term limits but I also don't think that
would be a a deal I I'll think about it
more though uh Dan Sherman said the term
limits could be like a 401k vesting an
elected official needs to serve so many
years to get benefits don't get
reelected no benefits
yeah I mean look
yeah the problem with all these ideas
Sheamus is that we ultimately get the
government that we vote for yeah it's
the people who are voting these guys tax
spin regulate grow the government and
you keep putting them back there and
back there and back there California is
a prime example we're we're having a
huge homeless problem we our schools are
near the bottom the average price of a
home is 175 above the national average
people are leaving for the first time
and yet they still keep voting these
people back in two-thirds of the State
Assembly Or democrats two-thirds of the
state senator Democrats Republicans need
not even show up for work and they could
pass one job killing bill after another
uh crucidist viewing says Larry do you
believe the Civil Rights act as
Constitution or even good in a
utilitarian sense
that's an interesting question
um I believe that had uh we not passed
the Civil Rights bill eventually Jim
Crow would have fallen of his own Merit
because nobody would have gone to a
restaurant nobody would have gone to a
state where we have Jim Crow laws So It
sped up something that I think would
have happened ultimately anyway yeah
well I think there's a good argument to
be made that companies want to be able
to serve a wider variety of people and
these laws being imposed on them
actually made it harder for them to make
a profit so not even from the
perspective of them wanting to care
about helping people you could just
imagine companies wanting to lobby and
push against these on the basis of it
costing them money you know and these
private companies private bus companies
they wanted to be able to serve
everybody of course the government had
to stop them from doing it which is what
the Jim Crow laws did Plessy Ferguson
was 1986. uh the case started because
the railroads wanted to be able to
service black people so they had a
light-skinned black person sit in the
white only area so that they would start
a lawsuit they thought they were going
to win they wanted the private sector
wanted people to be able to become of
course they wanted to make money well
and you can also Imagine for for buses
or other forms of public transit at this
time especially in the South with the
economic disparity that existed between
black people and white people it would
be less likely for a black person to own
a car so you actually had a larger
customer base there that they were
forced by the government to discriminate
against so there was every incentive on
their part not to do this
um we have from Carlo mango TV Mr Elder
how can we say uh how can we save
California or are we doomed like Sodom
and Gomorrah
well I liken it to a drug addict you got
to hit rock bottom and at that point you
begin to rethink your assumptions
apparently California has not yet hit
rock bottom I still am convinced most
voters are common sensical and if you
can explain to them that it is in their
best interest to do x y and they will I
believe that the captain of the Titanic
would have taken evasive action had he
known iceberg is ahead it's our job to
tell them hey voters Iceberg ahead take
evasive action well we are a minute over
so uh it's about do I get overtime no
you don't but maybe I do I'll ask you
know slavery is over believable slavery
is over maybe they should bring it back
it wouldn't have to work so hard I would
like to come back listen
um because you put your name on the show
this week you've sucked a whole minute
out of my life that show decided to put
my name on it because you knew I was the
best person for the job Hannah player
that's just all meritocracy works I want
you all to smash that language I have a
book called as ghost California oh no
I'm not I'm still going to give you time
to plug your stuff I just want to let
the audience
you know what you got to get your mind
out of the gutter so become a member.com
thank you for joining us Larry I'd like
to promote yes please go to my website
uh larryolder.com contribute one dollar
so I can get up there on that debate
stage and plug my stuff uh I've got a
book called as goals California my
mission to rescue the Golden State and
save America it comes out in September
you can pre-order it on Barnes Noble or
on amazon.com
well this was delightful I am the only
journalist in this room as said and
apparently I could be your future press
secretary
um thank you so much for joining us this
has been an absolute Delight both an
extremely informed and very fun
conversation
um I first and foremost think we should
all give a shout out to Sheamus who has
yo Sheamus thank you thank you if you
guys don't know Sheamus runs his own
company Freedom Tunes he has his own
life as it turns out and also he uh
really just did incredible work this
week and I'm so grateful to have been
able to be on the show with you every
night so yeah yeah great work well
you're a massive help by the way Hannah
Claire and I would have like study
sessions where she we would get stories
ready and so couldn't have done it
without you you know tremendous help it
takes a village to replace Temple so we
really all just started and again thank
you guys all for uh joining us all week
for putting up with some slight changes
and for our quirky personalities uh we
really do it all for you and speaking of
which I'm incredibly grateful that all
of you who became members and support my
work on timcast.com in the work of all
the other other journalists you should
follow at timcast news on Twitter and
Instagram check us out on the read tab
of timcast.com again made possible by
you and I'm very proud of the work that
Adrian Norman Chris Bertman Cassandra
Fairbanks McDonald and Chris Carr and I
do if there's anyone else I'm forgetting
on the team I'm very sorry uh if you
want to follow me personally you can
find me on Twitter at HC brimlow you can
find me on Instagram hannerclow.b and
you can check out the latest episode of
cool to World thanks so much
all right guys oh wait sorry
guys
what was the South Side like yes at
Brett dasovic on both Twitter and
Instagram please go and check out pop
culture crisis Monday through Friday 3
P.M Eastern Standard Time me and Mary
have a lot of fun over there come join
us can I just three seconds yeah yeah
yeah I'm on Twitter at Larry Yoder I'm
on uh Instagram I'm on true social I'm
on thread I have a question for Sheamus
yes why is it we talking about your name
and how you yes yes sir why is it that
private detectives are called sheamuses
you know why it's it's because of a
hurtful racial stereotype that white
people were more likely or that Irish
people were more likely to become
members of law enforcement
something like that yeah I think I think
that detectives are more likely to be
Irish
place I know it hurts me it pains me
deeply I think it's because people named
Sheamus are really good at figuring
stuff out okay Scooby-Doo
uh yeah this has been a fun week it has
been stressful but uh I feel like we did
well Sheamus good job yeah man and you
did an awesome job by the way Serge was
this whole week giving me cues and just
extremely helpful so search passed me
past the Post-it note while I was on yes
we first started I don't have my glasses
I couldn't read this because I figured
it out I just want you to know Shane was
going
so oh okay so yes and the professional
lady host figured out he needed to his
search I need big letters okay yeah yeah
it isn't that I can't read I just need
big letters totally I need a bigger
posts
bigger Post-it notes are bigger paper
cranes just please oh yeah good point
could you please fill the top of your it
was just so you tilt the mic so please
fill the top of your tilt oh yeah aces
all right terribly would you please fill
your face
yeah yeah no I understand I wrote
terribly but you guys can follow me at
Twitter and I won't write stuff in my
handwriting I'll use the type of the
computer anyways thanks cheers what a
way to end shimcast this wonderful week
I want to ask all of you guys because I
have to make some plugs as well go over
to freedomtunes.com become a member if
you like me if you like what I do if you
want to support artists who are creating
content who aren't woke who are trying
to push back against the left-wing
narrative and just make entertaining
stuff go to freedomtunes.com become a
member you will get an extra cartoon
each week that people on the main
YouTube channel don't I want to thank
you all so much for watching if you want
to see more of me podcasting check out
my Rumble podcast shamer go on over
there subscribe thank you all so much
and I will see you when I'm back on the
show eventually
all right